Drei Spieltage sind gespielt bei manchen Vereinen, brennt schon wieder der sprichwörtliche Baum. Anderswo könnte die Laune kaum besser sein. Wir wollen drüber sprechen. Und das mache ich jetzt mit Michi Fischer vom Fürther Flachpass und den Nürnberger Nachrichten und Lisa Höfer von der Sportschau. Und nun im Programm, der Rasenfunk.
Lagerheim fliegt vorbei und der Ball ist im Tor. Und Augsburg ist oben. Rosti ist zu kurz ab, der lang genug für Willi Landgraf. Wagner, Martin Wagner.
Und das 1 zu 0. Markus Kurt aus dem Gewühl.
Alexander Schur!
Der Blick auf andere Ligen.
Ja und damit Hallo und herzlich Willkommen zurück zur Ligatour, zur 2. Liga der Männer. Ich bin Eva-Lotta Bohle und vor 3 Wochen saß ich zuletzt hier mit Marc. Und wir haben ja nach dem ersten Spieltag ein wenig auf die kommende Saison geblickt, ein bisschen Prognosen abgegeben. Mir wurde zugetragen, wir sollen heute bitte nicht über die Tabellentipps sprechen. Sämtliche Menschen sind etwas enttäuscht, sagen wir mal so, nach 3 Spieltagen. Aber es sind jetzt 3 Pflichtspiele mit dem Pokal 4 ins Land gezogen. Und wir wollen neben der Lage der Liga auf die Situation bei einigen Vereinen blicken. Aber noch mal zur Erinnerung, natürlich nicht so detailliert, wie ihr das aus der letzten Saison kennt. Also hier geht es jetzt nicht 90 Minuten lang nur um Fürth und Nürnberg. Wir haben das allererste Frankendorfer hier schon mal an Land gezogen. Aber Spaß zur Seite, ich muss zum Glück jetzt nicht alleine über die Teams sprechen, sondern ich darf die ersten beiden Mitglieder des neu gegründeten Rasenfunk Ligatour, 2. Liga All-Star-Teams begrüßen. Und zum einen freue ich mich sehr, dass Lisa Höfer mal wieder bei uns ist. Sie ist Redakteurin bei der Sportschau und hat sich passenderweise für uns Zeit genommen. Hallo Lisa.
Hallo, hallo in die Runde. Ich freue mich auch mit am Start zu sein.
Und dann freuen wir uns auch sehr über den dritten Kandidat hier in der Runde. Und zwar ist das Michi Fischer, wie gesagt, vom Fürth auf Lachbars und den Nürnbergern Nachrichten. Hallo Michi, schön, dass du auch wieder dabei bist.
Hallo Eva, hallo Lisa, hallo liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Und ja, es war sehr schön, dieses Intro mal wieder zu hören. Und deine Stimme klingt auch besser, Eva, als bei der ersten Aufnahme. Man merkt, dass da etwas Luft noch zwischen dem letzten Heimspiel und der Aufnahme war.
Ja, ja, ja, nicht ganz eigentlich. Also so viel lag da nicht zwischen, ne? Aber es war weniger Grund zur Freude. Lass es mich so formulieren. Und meine Stimme hat sich schon wieder beruhigt. Also sie ist im Trainingslager, hat sie überstanden und ist jetzt wieder da. Bevor wir in die Sendung starten, natürlich wie immer dahin, weiß, dass der Rasenfunk werbe-paywall- und sponsorenfrei ist. Er finanziert sich ausschließlich durch euch, Hörerinnen und Hörer. Wir freuen uns sehr darüber, dass ihr das eben auch ermöglicht, dass Marc und ich wieder hier als ModeratorInnen sitzen können und eben auch Gäste dabei haben. Und stellvertretend geht der Dank dafür in dieser Folge an Florian Machno, Michael Lennard, Wunderheiler und quasi83. Vielen Dank, dass ihr schon zu Supporterinnen zählt. Und wenn ihr das auch werden wollt, dann schaut doch einfach mal in den ShowNodes vorbei. Und dann könnt ihr euch auch noch registrieren. So, jetzt lass uns aber auf die Lage der Liga schauen. Und da haben wir uns mal überlegt, wir starten am Ende der Tabelle. Und zwar aus einem sehr guten Grund. Da steht nämlich der 1. FC Nürnberg. Der steht eben auf Platz 18 nach drei Spielen. Das einzige Team bisher ganz ohne Punkt. Im Pokal gab es nach Elfmeterschießen eine Niederlage gegen Ilaritissen. Grüße gehen raus an Caro Kipper. Das Elfmeterschießen oder dieses Pokalspiel zwischen Nürnberg und Ilaritissen fiel sehr oft in der Saisonsvorschau. Nach der 2-1-Niederlage am Freitag gegen Preußen Münster ist die Stimmung am Tiefpunkt. Lisa, du warst in Münster. Erzähl uns doch gerne mal ein bisschen was zum Spiel. Aber dann natürlich auch, wie fühlt sich das Herz eines FCN-Fans gerade so an?
Ja, ich habe es gerade schon ein bisschen im Vorgespräch gesagt. Meistens ging es immer bergab, wenn ich gerade im Podcast irgendwie war und ein bisschen hyped oder positiv war. Jetzt ist die Konstellation so ein bisschen anders. Also als Clubfan ist man ja vieles gewöhnt. Der Club ist Adept. Ich glaube, alle kennen uns, alle wissen es gerade. Fühlt man es schon wieder sehr. Ich sage mal so, ich bin schon mit dieser Grundeinstellung an Hoffnung und Optimismus nach Münster gefahren. Auf die Absteigertipps gucken wir ja zum Glück nicht. Ich habe aber Münster als Absteiger getippt und war dann auch mit so einer Haltung so, naja, also hier müsste es vielleicht jetzt schon klappen. Die ersten vier, fünf Minuten war ich positiv optimistisch und dachte so, okay, vielleicht geht was. Stimmung war gut. Ja, und dann kam einfach das Spiel und so ein bisschen die Realität und ja, die Halbzeit war, glaube ich, schon sehr ernüchternd. Nicht nur, weil es schon 2.0 für Münster stand, sondern auch einfach, weil man als Fan im Stadion, aber auch zu Hause, glaube ich, wenn man das Spiel verfolgt hat, und echt gesehen hat, dass da einfach gerade an ganz, ganz vielen Ecken und Enden nicht so richtig zusammenläuft. Ich habe gestern auch schon überlegt, wo steigt man denn überhaupt ein, wenn man den Club jetzt vielleicht nicht so sehr verfolgt hat? Wo ist irgendwie das größte Thema? Was ist eigentlich das, was man als erstes anspricht? Aber die Gesamtsituation ist schwierig, um es mal so zu formulieren. Und ich würde auch von einem Fehlstart sprechen, auch wenn andere Verantwortliche wie Jotisha Tialeksiu, Sportvorstand, ja das noch nicht ganz so werden würden. Also Fehlstart trifft es für mich und ich glaube, ganz, ganz viele andere aus der Bubble, auch aus der Fernszene schon sehr.
Man merkt auch am 1. FC Nürnberg, dass da diese Aufgeregtheit bei so großen Traditionsvereinungen ein bisschen schneller auch kommt. Also es gab schon beim Vokalspielen in Lattisen ja schon die erste Ansage des Vorsingers der Ultras für die Mannschaft und das nach dem dritten Saisonspiel zeigt ja auch schon, dass da vielleicht eine gewisse Grundaufgeregtheit da ist, die halt dann immer gerne bei so Vereinen ins Positive umschlägt, wenn es gut läuft, die aber halt auch schnell ins Negative umschlägt, wenn es immer nicht so gut läuft. Also als Angestellter in einer Sportredaktion mit FC Nürnberg kriegt man ja sehr viel mit, was da passiert. Und ich fand eigentlich, dass der 1. FC Nürnberg in den letzten Monaten, ja fast schon Jahren, vieles gut gemacht hat, dass er auch einen guten Weg war als Gesamtverein. So diese Feierlichkeiten rund um den Geburtstag, so 125-Jährigen waren gut, das Trikot des Liga am Freitag im Stadion anhatte, das Jubiläumstrikot, das wurde ja 50.000-mal verkauft, das war der Renner überhaupt, vielleicht das schönste Adidas-Trikot, muss ich sogar als Viertel sagen, so was es in den letzten Jahren einfach gab, sehr schön. Die Feierlichkeiten im Stadion waren gut, man hat irgendwie so alte Helden auch geehrt, das kam ja auch wie von der Fan-Szene, man hat sein Strukturalsdefizit abgebohrt, man hat Talente rausgebracht, man hat ein NLZ, das funktioniert. Also eigentlich sieht da sehr vieles sehr gut aus. Ja, dann kommt irgendwie dieser Saisonstart, der passt so gar nicht in diese Reihe von diesem guten Bild, das ich auch so vom 1. FC Nürnberg gewonnen hatte, von dem besseren Bild. Aber klar, am Ende kommt es halt darauf an, nur Talente auszubilden. Sondern man braucht auch eine gute Mannschaft für die 2. Liga. Und wenn man drei der besten Spieler der letzten Saison verkauft, mit Ziemers, mit Jeltsch zum Beispiel, die einfach jetzt wechseln. Kastrup hat jetzt auch gespielt bei Gladbach am ersten Spieltag schon und da keinen adäquaten Ersatz dafür holt, dann sieht es vielleicht auch einfach so aus, wie es jetzt momentan aussieht.
Ja, und ich glaube, das Problem ist auch so ein bisschen, man hatte diese Spiele gegen Elbersberg, wo man spät das Späte-Gegentor dann gegen Darmstadt bekommen hat. Dann hattest du gegen Ilaatissen so das Gefühl, man dreht irgendwie das Spiel, dann kriegt man aber hinten raus doch wieder das 2-2. Und dann hatte man jetzt aber bei Münster das erste Mal das Gefühl, dass hast du ja auch eben gesagt, Lisa, da stand es halt zur Halbzeit schon 2-0 für Münster. Also da kannst du halt noch nicht mehr sagen, ja hinten raus irgendwie Kräfte haben nicht gereicht, obwohl das halt am Anfang der Saison auch eigentlich nicht der Fall sein sollte. Das sind wir mal ganz ehrlich. Aber ich kann das schon verstehen, dass die Laune da dann auch nicht gut ist, weil klar, es ist auch wieder ein Umbruch durch die Spieler, die man verloren hat. Aber man hat halt auch irgendwie so das Gefühl, da läuft es halt auch nicht zusammen. Und ich glaube, Marco und ich hatten auch irgendwie gesagt, der Chara passt nicht. Also das passt einfach nicht. Das sind einfach ganz, ganz viele Fragezeichen. Es wird super viel Hoffnung auf irgendwie einen Stepanov gesetzt, der dann überall schon als ukrainischer Harland bezeichnet wurde und Co. Und da natürlich der Druck super hochgehalten wird. Aber ja, es sieht halt auch einfach nicht schön aus, was Nürnberg spielt. Also es fehlt irgendwie auch so ein bisschen einfach diese spielerischen Elemente, diese kleinen individuellen Momente, die man vielleicht in der letzten Saison hatte.
Ich glaube, was so ein bisschen ein Punkt ist, wenn man sich an die Situation von vor einem Jahr zurück erinnert, da fing es ja ähnlich holprig an, da hat man aber das ein oder andere Spiel noch gezogen. Also ich glaube, das ist jetzt schon was für diese Grundstimmung gerade, dass du so negativ werden lässt. Ich stimme dir total zu, Michi. Also ich habe das auch so erlebt, die letzten Wochen und Monate. Man hatte als Fan das Gefühl, man schwimmt auf einer sehr positiven Welle. Man hat dann schon nicht mehr die Ergebnisse geholt, das muss man schon auch sagen. Wir hatten ja dann als Clubfans so ein bisschen vielleicht noch geschielt. So geht da noch was in Sachen Aufstiegskampf. Das war dann sehr schnell auch im Frühling vorbei. Damit konnte man sich aber irgendwie arrangieren, weil man irgendwie schon froh war, dass man mit dem Abstieg nichts zu tun hat, dass man irgendwie das Gefühl hatte, da findet sich gerade eine Mannschaft, da findet sich eine gute Grundstimmung. Jetzt ist zum Beispiel der ganze Sturm auch einfach wieder weg. Siemals habt ihr gerade angesprochen, Emreli auch Richtung Lautern abgewandert. Auch einen Antiest, den man ausgeliehen hatte, konnte man nicht halten, nicht bezahlen. Dann fängt man an so einer Baustelle wirklich wieder von Null an. Ihr habt die jungen Spieler, die junge Mannschaft gerade erwähnt. Das glaube ich, ist etwas, was man gerade ganz stark spürt. Wo ich auch in Münster ehrlicherweise das Gefühl hatte, ich weiß auch gerade gar nicht, wer da so richtig vorne weggehen soll, wenn dann auch ein Justwahn vielleicht nicht so funktioniert. Da sind einfach ganz, ganz viele junge Spieler dabei, die so ein bisschen Führung auf dem Platz im Team bräuchten und so richtig die Leadership sehe ich dabei nicht so vielen. Janda, ja, aber auch noch ein ganz, ganz junger. Jilmaz begeistert mich auch. Aber das können halt nicht die einzigen Säulen in so einem jungen Team sein. Deswegen hoffe ich sehr, auch wenn wir heute nicht über den Transfermarkt sprechen wollen, dass da in den nächsten Tagen noch was passiert, nicht nur in Sachen Achter, sondern auch in Sachen Erfahrung würde ich mir das so aus der Fanbrille sehr, sehr wünschen.
Beim Thema Führung ist mir gerade so ein Name eingefallen. Das war ja auch ein Thema am Freitag beim 1. FC Nürnberg, nämlich dass man den Kapitän Robin Knoche gleich mal demontiert hat am dritten Zweitligaspietag und ihn auf die Bank gesetzt hat. Also das ist ja auch schon ein Symptom dieser Krise, dass man den Spieler, den man unbedingt geholt hat, um eine junge Mannschaft zu führen, um mit der Kapitänsbinde zu vertrauen, damit er eben die vielen Talente an die Hand nimmt und indem man extra auch seine taktische Formation umgebaut hat. Letztes Jahr hat man teilweise Viererkette gespielt, für Robin Knoche dann auf die Dreierkette umgestellt und bislang Robin Knoche auch in der ganzen Saison unglücklich. Deswegen auch von Miroslav Klose auf die Bank gesetzt in Münster. Und klar, das ist auch ein Symptom dieses Ganzen, dass man einfach dann, dass die Spieler, die funktionieren müssen, dafür holt man ja so erfahrenen Spieler, dass sie funktionieren, dass sie vorangehen und wenn sie das nicht machen, dann ist es umso schwieriger. Jetzt ist Fabio Gruber ja der Kapitän und der sah ja auch bei beiden Gegentoren der 1. Halbzeit nicht gut aus. Das ist dann, also wenn dann deine beiden Kapitäne schon mal nicht die Leistung bringen, die man sich von ihnen erhofft, dann natürlich schwer zu erwarten, dass jetzt dann Spieler, die aus unteren Ligen kamen, die ganz jung sind wie Stepanov, dass die dann jetzt plötzlich da alles retten. Das kann ja fast gar nicht funktionieren. Da muss ja die Achse funktionieren und das kriegt man ja auch viel mit, wenn man so hier in Franken wohnt. In den letzten Wochen und Monaten viel oft das Wort, der Club braucht Achsenspieler, aber irgendwie sind die immer noch nicht da. Diese Achse sucht man immer noch vergebens. Die Frage ist, ob es jetzt, wenn man innerhalb der nächsten Tage noch Achsenspieler holt, sofort funktioniert. Die haben dann trotzdem keinerlei Vorbereitung mitgemacht. Die haben die ersten vier Saisonspiele nicht mitgemacht. Da kommt die Länderspielpause dann auch gelegen. Aber wie wir schon hatten, der Kader ist schief. Da gibt es vielleicht sogar noch mehr Baustellen, als es mit einem oder zwei Spielern für die Acht vielleicht getan ist. Das ist der erste Nürnberg. Gleich ist das schon ein bisschen eine Großbaustelle gerade. Und nach diesen schönen Monaten, wie gesagt, ich wiederhole mich. Das ist dann komisch zu sehen, aber irgendwie passt sie auch zu der 2. Liga.
Ja, und diese Liga ist halt auch undankbar. Du hast halt eben keine Zeit, dich zurechtzufinden. Du wirst halt gnadenlos bestraft an den ersten Spieltagen, wenn du da nicht wach bist. Und das ist halt, glaube ich, dann landest du halt eben schnell auf Platz 18. Und ich glaube, du hast halt auch erst ein Tor geschossen. Und das war halt Freitagabend. Ich glaube, das kommt halt dann auch noch dazu. Also und wie gesagt, man hätte halt sagen können, bist du zu diesem 2-2 von Illa Tissen, okay, das könnte jetzt halt so ein Umschlagmoment sein, aber war es halt nicht. Und dann ist es halt irgendwie doppelt bitter, wenn du dann da eben auch noch im Elfmeterschießen, gut, das ist dann eh so eine Sache, aber dann halt auch noch als Verlierer hinten rausgehst, das ist ja, also könnte besser laufen, vorsichtig ausgedrückt.
Ja, ich glaube, dass der Kader so, wie er ist, nicht rund ist, das konnte man ja auch, wenn man die Vorbereitung verfolgt hat, schon an der einen oder anderen Stelle sehen. Deswegen hat es mich nicht ganz so überrascht, dass es nicht so rund lief, aber man steht natürlich jetzt als Club unter einem ganz anderen Druck, wenn man so gar kein Spiel sieht. Also ich glaube, die Unruhe wäre wahrscheinlich schon auch da. Hätte man jetzt nur einen Punkt oder zwei, oder wäre man im Pokal dringeblieben. Aber so ist es halt direkt Alarmstufe dunkelrot, um es vielleicht so zu formulieren, dass sich das jetzt in so einer Negativspirale einfach nochmal auch ganz, ganz anders äußert. Miroclose hat es ja selber gesagt, am Ende ist Fußball ein Ergebnis-Sport und die Ergebnisse stimmen halt überhaupt nicht. Und das wird jetzt gerade auch nicht übertüncht, dass man glücklich im Pokal weiterkommt oder dass man vielleicht doch einspielen noch zieht. Also das Spiel gegen Elbersberg, das hätte man nicht verlieren müssen, nicht verlieren dürfen. Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr euch erinnert, bekommt man da vielleicht einen Elfmeter in der Schlussphase oder fängt man sich nicht nach dem Standard das Tor, dann geht man da vielleicht mit einem 0-0 oder auch mit einem glücklichen 1-0 vom Platz. Und dann sieht die Tabelle schon deutlich besser aus. Dann ist vielleicht die Situation auch nicht ganz so drastisch, wie sie sich jetzt anfühlt, aber im Moment bin ich sehr gespannt und würde schon auch fast sagen, so Paderborn am Freitag Heimspiel. Ich will jetzt nicht sagen, das wird schon ein kleines Endspiel, aber wenn wir ehrlich sind, wird es natürlich ein kleines Endspiel, auch wenn ich die Letzte bin, die so auf Trainerentlassungen irgendwie guckt oder da gucken will. Aber ich glaube, wenn man da auch nicht punktet und wenn man sich da nicht anders präsentiert, dann wird es ungemütlich an vielen Stellen.
Die Frage ist dann natürlich, wie sehr bringt es dann ein verunsichteter Team, auch noch den Trainer zu entziehen? Vielleicht für ein, zwei Spieler ja doch durchaus meistens der Grund, überhaupt erst nach Nürnberg zu wechseln. Du hast es gesagt, das ist jetzt eben die Spiel gegen Paderborn. Dann hat man ja zum Glück, sage ich mal, eine Länderspielpause, wo man sich wirklich noch mal drauf konzentrieren kann, was brauchen wir? Und danach geht es dann halt ausserz nach Karlshuhe. Jetzt auch nicht die dankbarste Aufgabe. Zuhause gegen Bochum und dann zuhause gegen Hertha. Also dann hast du eben auch zwei Heimspiele hintereinander. Und ich glaube schon, dass du da, also ich glaube schon, dass Nürnberg den Turnaround schaffen kann. Aber erstens, du brauchst halt Spieler, die halt keine Perspektivspieler sind, sondern jetzt halt wirklich sofort helfen. Wie ihr schon gesagt habt, du brauchst jetzt Führungsspieler. Und du, also am sechsten Spieltag ungefähr, dann das erste Mal irgendwie mit einer Achse reinzugehen. Das wird halt auch irgendwie nicht funktionieren. Und ja, also ich, ich sage an der Stelle auch nochmal, also wie gesagt, wir wollen nicht über Transfer, aber es haben ja auch alle irgendwie mitgekriegt, dass Bielefeld und Nürnberg gleichzeitig um Marius Wöhrl irgendwie da geboolt haben. Und ja, das ist ein interessanter Spieler. Aber ich sage mal, aus Nürnberg-Perspektive habe ich es eh nicht so ganz verstanden, weil der halt erstens nicht fit ist. Also das ist ja unter anderem einer der Gründe, warum er bei Tietz auch nicht gespielt hat. Und er ist ja auch ein junger Spieler. Dass der da als, weiß ich nicht, Führungsperson vorangehen kann, hätte ich an der Stelle jetzt tatsächlich auch mal bezweifelt. Also aus. Ich bin am Ende des Tages auf Rudrum, aber habe ich dann einfach aus Transfersicht, aus Kaderplanungssicht nicht verstanden. Und das ist eben die Frage, Marco und ich haben es gesagt, ob Miroc, also dieser Kader, der da hingesetzt wurde, der passt halt nicht. Wir haben es jetzt öfter schon gesagt, er ist schief. Und dann ist halt wirklich die Frage, naja, muss der Trainer dafür bestraft werden, wenn der, ich sage jetzt mal streng genommen, der Sportvorstand einen Fehler gemacht hat.
Also ich glaube, der Grund, warum man Wörle holen wollte, ist ja auch, dass immer noch, es ist immer noch unklar, ob Caspar Janda bleibt. Klar, er sollte jetzt noch mal bei Stuttgart wechseln, dem war dann das Preisschild zu hoch. Es war so quasi der umgedrehte Volte-Made-Poker, war Stuttgart dann das Preisschild, also war der Preis zu teuer, den der Club für Caspar Janda wollte. Man hörte ja immer wieder von 15 Millionen, das ist schon auch viel nach einer guten 2. Liga-Saison, auch wenn Caspar Janda ein sehr guter Spieler ist. Ich bin mehrmals ja auch live spielen sehen, in der letzten Saison mit den Spielen gegen Fürth, da war er auch meistens ziemlich gut. Aber es ist ja immer noch unklar, ob der bleibt jetzt. Also klar, der Club hat erst mal gesagt, er wird sich verkauft an den VfB Stuttgart vermutlich, weil der VfB nicht bereit ist, das zu zahlen. Aber man wäre ja offenbar bereit gewesen, ihn gehen zu lassen, wenn denn ein entsprechendes Angebot gekommen wäre. Dann hätte man seinen 4. und vielleicht sogar den besten Spieler der letzten Saison einfach auch noch verloren. Und vielleicht muss man da auch schon ein bisschen vorbauen. Und es kann ja auch nicht schaden, noch mal einen weiteren spielstarken Achter zu haben im Kader. Weil das beim Club ja auch gerade fehlt. Also die erste Halbzeit am Freitag in Münster hat ja auch eins gezeigt, dass es nicht daran liegt, dass da jetzt zwei junge Stürmer sind, die vielleicht nicht die Tore schießen, die die Teamart letztes Jahr geschossen haben im Rallye, sondern das auch an der Kreativität mangelt. Also ich habe gerade noch mal die Daten angeschaut. Man hatte 0,2 Expected Goals in der ersten Halbzeit gegen Preußen Münster, die letztes Jahr trotzdem fast abgestiegen wären. Klar, Preußen Münster ist ein anderes als das der letzten Saison. Die spielen deutlich besseren Fußball. Aber trotzdem fehlt da ja komplette Kreativität nach vorne. Wie du sagst, Eva, das war das erste Tor am Freitag jetzt in der zweiten Hälfte. Und auch in der Vorbereitung hat man nicht viele Tore geschossen, außer gegen Bezirksligisten vielleicht oder Kreisligisten. Aber ansonsten hat man da auch nicht oft getroffen. Also deswegen hätte ich den World Transfer verstanden, wenn man ihn gemacht hätte. Und das ganze Klub wahrscheinlich auch bemüht. Weil man hat ja sonst keine Alternativen mehr im Vordergrund.
True, ja, richtig erinnernd.
Ja, also Caspar Yanda, ich hoffe sehr, dass er bleibt. Das ist so ein bisschen das letzte Fün- Fün-Fün-Hoffnung, glaube ich, für den ein oder anderen Fan.
Perfekt.
Wenn wir Caspar Yanda jetzt auch noch aus Clubsicht verlieren würden, dann wird es eine harte Saison. Du hast das aber schon ganz gut zusammengefasst, Michi. Ich habe auch noch mal so ein bisschen ins Zahlenwerk geguckt und so das eine oder andere ist ja eine gefühlte Wahrheit, die man manchmal so hat, aber wenn dann auch die Zahlen zeigen, Standards sind zum Beispiel auch, was ich mir jedes Jahr schon seit vielen Jahren denke, es wäre schön, würde man da beim Club auch ein bisschen mehr rausholen und würde da was passieren. Auch das war ja eine Baustelle, die man in Münster mit sieben Ecken irgendwie auch gut sehen konnte. Und ich glaube, jetzt rein aus der Erinnerung, es war keine Ecke so gut getreten oder hat so viel Gefahr vermittelt, dass ich irgendwie im Stadion gedacht hätte, die nächste Ecke bringt uns jetzt bestimmt ein Tor ein. Da sind so viele Themen, so viele Baustellen, dass es spannend aus neutraler Sicht wird, das zu verfolgen. Als Fan macht man sich die ein oder andere Sorge. Robin Knoche haben wir auch gerade kurz angerissen. Generell ist das vielleicht so ein bisschen der Hauptpunkt, wo ich sagen würde, da wird es spannend zu sehen, was Miru Klose macht und wo ich auch sage, da würde ich mir vom Trainer ein bisschen eine klarere Handschrift, eine klarere Entscheidung wünschen, wie man jetzt spielt. Dreierkette, Viererkette, wir haben es gerade schon angerissen. Robin Knoche, Dreierkette, ja, das ist das, was funktioniert hat. Warum man dann auch umgestellt hat, letzte Saison jetzt die letzten beiden Spiele, sowohl im Pokal als auch gegen Münster, hat das mit der Viererkette natürlich deutlich besser funktioniert. Also ja, ich sehe auch, was man so von Clubseite gesehen hat, dass die zweite Halbzeit sowohl im Pokal als auch in Münster besser war. Ich finde, es ist noch weit weg von, ja, war doch alles gar nicht so schlimm und wir müssen nicht von Fehlstart sprechen und wir hätten die Spiele auch ziehen können. Also so würde ich das jetzt nicht formulieren, wenn man mich fragt. Aber ich würde auch sagen, dass das besser funktioniert hat. Führt aber natürlich dann zu einer Frage, geht man mit Robin Knoche da rein, demontiert man den Kapitän, hat man einen Führungsspieler oder nicht? Und das sind jetzt so Baustellen, da würde ich mir dann schon wünschen von Miro Klose, dass da ein bisschen eine klarere Handschrift reinkommt, weil so wirkt die Mannschaft für mich gerade sehr, sehr unsicher und ja, fast schon labil. Also sobald man irgendwie das Gegentor fängt, das erste, das zweite, glaube ich, ist schon aus Fansicht direkt irgendwie klar, okay, das wird jetzt schwer bis unmöglich, da was zu drehen und das war letzte Saison anders. Also da muss ich sagen, habe ich einen anderen Club gesehen und ja, das wird jetzt interessant, wie sich das entwickelt. Ich hoffe und freue mich an der Stelle auf die Länderspielpause in der Hoffnung, dass sich das bessert.
Und man hat jetzt auch nicht die Hoffnung des letzten Jahres, dass da so ein Derby gegen Fürth kommt. Das war letztes Jahr die Initialzinne und dafür, dass alles anders, alles besser wurde, weil wir uns zurückerinnern, da war Miro Klose ja auch nach diesem schwachen Saisonstart, der zwar nach Punkten okay war, aber spielerisch jetzt nicht so toll war, sag ich mal ausbaufähig. Da hatte man dieses Derby in Fürth, das man ja 4-0 gewonnen hat, und dann wurde ja danach alles besser. Und jetzt ist das Derby blöderweise erst am 15. Spieltag. Also die Hoffnung darf man als Club-Fan auch nicht haben. Das dauert noch bis dahin, das muss jetzt in anderen Spielen besser werden.
Ja, wir sind mal gespannt, was eben dieses Spiel gegen Paderborn bringt und dann eben auch das Transferfenster, wenn es geschlossen ist, sagen wir mal so. Da kann ich schon mal verraten. Wir werden tatsächlich dieses Mal nur ein Spieltag, nächstes Mal in der Besprechung drin haben. Wir sprechen am 1. Septemberwochenende wieder. Ich weiß, das ist Länderspielpause. Aber damit ihr nicht immer drei, mal vier, mal zwei Wochen warten müsst, haben wir uns dafür so entschieden. Und da wollen wir eben dann auch einen Blick auf den Transfermarkt bzw. das geschlossene Transferfenster blicken und schauen wieder, wie die 2. Liga-Vereine sich geschlagen haben. Aber Nürnberg ist ja, man könnte sagen, aus Nürnberger Sicht, glücklicherweise nicht der einzige Klub, der noch so ein bisschen am kriseln ist, sondern Hertha BSC, der ist auf Platz 17 und zwar auch noch ohne Sieg. Im Pokal gab es zwar den Sieg im Elfmeterschießen gegen Preußen Münster, aber ich sag mal so, wenn ich da mal ein bisschen auf meiner Timeline quergelesen habe zwischen den Hertha-Fans, die waren alle sehr glücklich und haben sich geradezu geschämt, dass man dieses Spiel gewonnen hat. Ja, in der Liga zwei torlose Remis gegen Karlsruhe und Darmstadt. Es ist jetzt nicht so, als würde man sich überhaupt gar keine Torchancen heraus spielen und als wäre alles ganz furchtbar schlecht, aber man muss einfach sagen, bisher, Michi, reicht es einfach nicht, um den selbst formulierten Anspruch eines Aufstiegskandidaten gerecht zu werden. Wird es mir dazu stimmen?
Da stimme ich dir sehr zu und es tut mir weh, weil wer die Tabellentipps gesehen hat, ich habe auch die Hertha als Aufsteiger getippt, weil ich von Stefan Leithl immer noch überzeugt bin. Wenn ich hier spiele, in Fürth, denke ich mir immer, wie schön es war, als Stefan Leithl hier war. Aber irgendwie denkt sich auch Stefan Leithl, wenn er jetzt in Berlin oder Hannover an der Seitellinie steht, dass es vielleicht auch in Fürth ganz schön war. Weil man sieht diesen Stefan Leithl-Fußball nicht mehr, den man damals hier gesehen hat. Ich habe eigentlich viel Potenzial gesehen, um mit gutem Fußball, mit sehr vielen guten Fußballern in dieser Mannschaft, in der 2. Liga einfach guten Fußball zu spielen. Das sieht man bei der Hertha momentan einfach nicht. Ich glaube auch, dass Fabian Reze zum Beispiel auch da geblieben ist, aber bislang auch nicht so in Erscheinung getreten, dass man sagt, Wahnsinn, das ist der Unterschiedspieler, der Bestspieler der 2. Liga, das man von ihm erhofft hat. Und klar, da wird auch der Druck wieder größer werden. Das ist ja auch klar. Stefan Leithl ist in Hannover jetzt schon mit seinem 3-Jahresplan vorzeitig gescheitert, auch wenn Scheitern immer ein großes Wort ist. Und ob man jetzt in Berlin so lange zuschauen kann, wenn das weiterhin nicht läuft, ist auch die Frage. Weil irgendwann muss die Hertha mal wieder hoch, weil da ist von den Strukturen ein Bundesliga-Verein. Und klar, da hat man auch schon ein bisschen abgebaut vielleicht im Budget, aber trotzdem ist es ein Bundesliga-Verein. Wenn man mal dort im Stadion war, ist es auch ein Bundesliga-Standort. Das haben wir blöderweise auch sieben Jahre lang über den HSV gesagt, das ist auch ein Bundesliga-Standort. Die haben es wieder geschafft jetzt, aber wir wissen auch mit jedem Jahr, dass man abgehängt ist in der 2. Liga, wird es schwieriger. Und das sehe ich bei der Hertha schon ein bisschen auch so kommen, so eine HSVisierung, dass man halt einfach jedes Jahr ein bisschen abbaut, jedes Jahr ein bisschen schwächer wird. Und das sieht man jetzt ja gerade zum Saisonstart und auch da gab es schon Diskussionen auch im Forum darüber, dass es vielleicht sogar ganz seltsam ist, die Hertha so als Aufschließkandidat zu tippen, weil der Kader auch da schief ist. Vielleicht habe ich da mich zu wenigen der Tiefe damit beschäftigt, dass man mit allen 18 Vereinen da jedes Detail des Kaders kennen, aber für mich von außen betrachtet, auch wenn ich so die letzten Jahre der Hertha gesehen habe, die ganze Wucht dieses Vereins, dann war das für mich ein Aufschließkandidat, womöglich lag ich da falsch. Und die Tabelle sagt uns ja gerade, dass vielleicht mancher da falsch lag.
Ja, Lisa sagst du gerne erst.
Ich wollte nur gestehen, ich habe auch die Hertha als Aufsteiger getippt. Da bin ich noch nicht ganz so bei der Schwarzmalerei dabei, ehrlicherweise, was das angeht. Also von dem Tipp würde ich mich jetzt noch nicht komplett verabschieden, ehrlicherweise. Ja, Blick auf die Tabelle, ja, die ersten Spiele stimme ich dir komplett zu, Michi. Ich finde, es gibt so ein paar Faktoren, wo man, glaube ich, schon auch ein bisschen Hoffnung haben kann, wenn man jetzt aus der Härterbrille drauf guckt. Also die Verletztenliste die letzten Wochen war da ja sehr, sehr lang. Ich weiß gar nicht, acht, neun Spieler, die man durchaus auch in der ersten Elf sehen könnte. Gerade Seguin Demme, finde ich, waren zwei so Personalien, wo man schon auch irgendwie gemerkt hat im Mittelfeld, ja, da fehlen Spieler. Fabi Reese, noch nicht so der Unterschiedsspieler, ich muss gestehen, hätte der das Siegtor gemacht, würden wir vielleicht heute auch wieder ein bisschen anders über das Spiel sprechen, weil Chancen waren ja da. Also das würde ich jetzt eher so ein bisschen als Chancenwucher und nichts ging irgendwie rein oder mein Opa sagt immer ganz gerne, als hatten sie kein Glück und dann kam auch noch Pech dazu. So das schreibt es für mich vielleicht schon ein bisschen mit dem Blick jetzt auf das Spiel gegen Darmstadt. Also das hätte nicht null null ausgehen müssen, sollen, dürfen. Dass ich da jetzt aber noch nicht so kritisch draufgucken würde, wie vielleicht beim ein oder anderen Club oder wie gerade beim Club.
Und du hast gerade schon gesagt Lisa, Seguin und Demme, aber es hat trotzdem Seguin und Demme. Demme ist 33, Seguin ist 30. Es kann halt auch sein, dass Spiele in diesem Alter mal verletzt ausfallen. Also die werden halt wahrscheinlich beide nicht 34 Spiele machen. Und bei Paul Seguin kam er im Sommer jetzt neu dazu. Er ist ja so der Lieblingsspieler von Stefan Leitl. Ich habe das ja auch begleitet, als er hier war in Fürth. Der war einer der Bausteine, dass Fürth aufgestiegen ist. Und Stefan Leitl hat schon ein bisschen die Tendenz, seine Mannschaft nachzubauen von früher. Hatte Hannover ja auch gehabt mit vielen Spielern, die er aus Fürth geholt hat, die dann da auch plötzlich nicht mehr so gut funktioniert haben. Und ich mag Paul Seguin, ich mag den Spielertypen, aber er ist halt einfach auch fünf Jahre älter als damals, als er 14 im Aufstieg geführt hat. Und jetzt ist er wieder verletzt. Demme hat auch nicht, also gesagt 33. Da kann auch immer wieder was passieren. Also da ist schon auch viel Hoffnung dabei, dass es einfach gut geht mit diesen Spielern, die der Trainer auch kennt, die er gerne hat. Bislang können sie es nicht zeigen. Aber klar, die Hertha wird nicht auf Platz 17 stehen am 34. Spieltag. Da gehe ich schon auch mit. Das wird noch besser werden, ob sie jetzt aufsteigen wird. Das kann, glaube ich, kann keiner und keine von uns seriös prognostizieren.
Ja, ich würde per se auch erst mal sagen, gut, Darmstadt eben auch mit sieben Punkten nach drei Spielen stehen auf Platz 2. Die hatten eben diesen Sieg gegen Bochum zu Beginn, dann eben diesen Last-Minute-Sieg mehr oder weniger gegen Nürnberg. Und ich meine, es ist ja auch schon eine Leistung dann am Ende, Tja, Ernst hat auch hervorragend gehalten, wenn er gebraucht wurde. Ist natürlich auch extrem wichtig, einfach aus härter Sicht vielleicht da auf jeden Fall auch mal die Null zu halten, dem Torhüter da so ein bisschen den Push zu geben. Aber ich glaube einfach, wenn man eben dieses Münsterspiel im Pokal gesehen hat, wo man wirklich einfach sagen muss, es war über weite Strecken eine Offenbarung und keine gute. Also das war halt, ich meine, Münster hat Hertha zum Teilen gespielt, so sehr dominiert, dass man wirklich fragen musste, okay, also da ist halt fast ein Liga-Unterschied zu sehen. Und dann muss man halt noch mal gucken, woher kommt Preußen Münster. Michi, du hast es eben gesagt, es ist halt immer noch der Verein, der fast abgestiegen ist. Klar, sie spielen anderen Fußball und sie, für meine Sinne, spielen auch besser, als ich sie tatsächlich erwartet habe. Das funktioniert enorm gut schon in der 2. Liga unter Alex M., aber noch mal Hertha BSC hat niemand, hat Hertha in dieser Ecke gedrängt, von wegen sie müssten ja jetzt mal aussteigen, sondern das haben sie selber gemacht. Und selber rund um den Verein gibt es diese Ansagen. Und deshalb ist es also, ich habe es an der ersten Folge gesagt, ich glaube, das kann ihnen richtig auf die Füße fallen. Dass es ihnen jetzt schon auf die Füße fällt, hätte ich jetzt nicht gedacht. Aber klar, ich glaube auch nicht, dass wir sie am Ende auf Platz 17 sehen werden. Aber was bei mir, also, man muss sagen, Leitel verstehe ich zum Teil noch nicht so ganz, wo er taktisch und auch von der Ausstellung her hin will. Also ich sehe da manchmal einfach noch nicht so die Konsequenz. Also irgendwie Dardai hatte absolute Gruselspiele, der durfte aber irgendwie die ganze Zeit. Okay, jetzt doppelt bitter, jetzt durfte Kolber, hat gegen Darmstadt ein super Spiel gemacht, musste dann nach 67 Minuten verletzt ausgewechselt werden. Na also, wie du hast es gesagt, er ist kein Glück, dann auch noch Pech so ungefähr. Das kommt dann auch dazu. Aber du musst halt trotzdem einfach sagen, also du musst halt irgendwann rauskommen aus, okay, wir haben zumindest hinten die Null gehalten und wir hatten ja, der XG-Wert war höher als Darmstadt. Das sagt da keiner. Aber man muss halt sagen, ich fand die Aussagen halt nach dem Münsterspiel, ich glaube, das waren die, ich glaube Toni Leissner, der da zum Teil diese Leistung verharmlos hat, wo ich dachte so, ey, also im Elfmeterschießen gegen Münster weiterzukommen, weiß ich jetzt nicht, also weiß ich jetzt wirklich nicht, ob ich danach so was sagen würde. Ja, das ist glaube ich das, wo ich bei Hertha eher sage, da passt bei mir einfach die, habe ich das Gefühl, da passt in der Wahrnehmung ganz viel nicht, was man so von außen sieht, wenn man auf den Kaderhund, wenn man auf den Verein guckt. Wir gucken mal gerade noch, ich bin hier top vorbereitet, ich habe irgendwann aufgehört, mir aufzuschreiben, wer gegen wen spielt. Das ist einfach ganz hervorragend. Also schauen wir aber mal gerade drauf, was denn die nächsten Gegner der Hertha sind. Also es ist am Freitag die SV Elbersberg und nach der Länderspielpause dann auswärts bei Hannover und dann zu Hause gegen Paderborn. Also das ist auch durchaus interessante Mesh-ups und wenn du eben dich als Ausstiegskandidat etablieren willst, musst du da halt punkten. Also mindestens mal gegen Paderborn und Hannover. Also gegen Elbersberg sowieso, aber wir kennen, wir wissen alle, Hertha hat noch so ein leichtes Elbersberg-Traum, glaube ich, aus der letzten Saison. Mal schauen, wie sie das überstehen. Aber genau, also ich würde per se sagen, das wäre erstmal ein Verein, wo ich anders als bei Nürnberg jetzt nicht sage, okay, die brauchen auf jeden Fall 1, 2, 3, 4, 5 Spieler noch, jetzt noch Vortransferfenster ändern. Aber sie müssen halt einfach irgendwie mal so eine vernünftige Stammelf, glaube ich, zusammenkriegen, die eben so einen gewissen Leistungsdurchschnitt trägt. Und dann sollten sie halt auch anfangen, vorne die Tore zu machen. Das war ja gegen Münster durchaus auch schon ein Problem. Kommen wir weiter zu einem Verein, der endlich seinen ersten Sieg feiern konnte, könnte man so sagen. Und das ist Fortuna Düsseldorf. Und die konnten gegen Paderborn mit 2-1 gewinnen. Nachdem man ja gegen Hannover verloren hatte, am ersten Später gegen Bielefeld. Aber man konnte zumindest auch schon im Pokal gegen Schweinfurt gewinnen. Das war ein Vogelbildespiel, ehrlich gesagt. Ja, es gab gegen Paderborn eine Umstellung vor allem auf Außen, die man in Teilen, glaube ich, schon sich angedeutet hatte im Pokal mit Rossmann und Lundahl. Ein bisschen überraschend, dass Christensinn eben da draußen geblieben ist. Aber das hat vor allem in der ersten Halbzeit enorm gut funktioniert. Cedric Itten natürlich direkt wieder mit einem Tor. Musliha auch. Man war auch 80 Minuten in Überzahl. Da hat man sehr lange wenig draus gemacht. Aber generell muss man sagen, Lisa, einfach nur vielleicht einmal so kleine Stimmungs. Wie siehst du Düsseldorf in dieser Saison?
Ja, also ich glaube, was für Düsseldorf jetzt ganz, ganz wichtig war, dass man wirklich einfach mal diese drei Punkte jetzt mitgenommen hat. Ich glaube, das ist genau das, was es jetzt braucht, um da so ein bisschen Ruhe reinzubekommen. Ja, Düsseldorf glaube ich für viele auch ein Aufstiegskandidat gewesen. Ich finde, die haben sich clever verstärkt. Ippen hast du gerade schon angesprochen. Azuzi finde ich auch ein spannender Spieler als Sechser. Deswegen glaube ich, haben sie das gar nicht so schlecht so geplant für dieses Jahr. Klar, auch einige Abgänge, auch einige Säulen, die man da verloren hat. Aber ich muss sagen, so Düsseldorf wäre für mich auch eine Mannschaft, die ich im oberen Drittel sehe, dass sie da jetzt wirklich noch sehr, sehr anfällig, gerade in der Abwehr, ich glaube, 5-1 gegen Bielefeld können wir gerne noch mal droppen, um dir ein Lächeln ins Gesicht zu zaubern. Das hat vielleicht der eine oder andere auch schon wieder vergessen. Nach dem Spiel war ich sehr besorgt und dachte so, okay, wer Düsseldorf als Aufstiegskandidat getippt hatte, puh, weiß ich jetzt nicht. Also da sieht man schon noch Baustellen. Das Pokalspiel hast du auch gerade angesprochen. Das habe ich mir witzigerweise auch im Einzelspiel angeguckt, weil Schweinfurt so ein bisschen Local Hood in meiner fränkischen Heimat ist und war auch überrascht, wie gut die mitgespielt haben und dass man da nicht so einen deutlichen Klassenunterschied sehen konnte an der einen oder anderen Stelle. Das, ich glaube, so ein bisschen Anspruch und Wirklichkeit ist da, glaube ich, jetzt gerade ein großes Thema. So klare Aufstiegskandidat, boah, sehe ich nicht. So wie die ersten Spiele liefen, waren jetzt aber auch die ersten Spiele und die drei Punkte, glaube ich, bringen erstmal ein bisschen Ruhe rein, um sich da zu sortieren. Ich glaube, das ist so für das Team, auch für Daniel Thun eine gute Situation an der Stelle. Ich habe nicht im Kopf, vielleicht hast du das auf dem Schlauen Zettel, Eva, wer da jetzt als nächstes kommt bei Düsseldorf. Das könnte natürlich jetzt in Sachen Länderspielpause dann auch nochmal so ein kleiner Faktor sein. Aber erstmal, glaube ich, kann man da durchatmen, sieht aber schon, da ist auch noch ein bisschen was zu tun.
Also ich kann ganz kurz sagen, Karlsruhe am Samstagabend dann auswärts nach der Länderspielpause in Münster und zuhause gegen Darmstadt. Also durchaus, wenn man sich da eben rausarbeiten sollte, könnten das sehr interessante Spiele werden, obwohl ich auch sagen muss, ich hatte so ein bisschen das Gefühl, Tune musste jetzt halt auch mit den Neuzugängen schauen, also mit was für einer Elf gehe ich denn rein. War natürlich undankbar, muss man auch sagen, mit zwei Niederlagen zu starten. Gut, Bielefeld nehmen wir jetzt mal so ein bisschen zu Seite, das war Unterzahl. Klar, man darf sich trotzdem nicht so fünf Gegentore fangen, ich glaube, das ist uns auch auch klar. Aber man kann auch gleichzeitig sagen, lieber diese Niederlagen jetzt als halt irgendwie Mitte-Ende der Saison. Und dann muss ich sagen, also, again, gegen Paderborn, das war keine 90 Minuten Hurra-Fußball. Und ich glaube, ich sage mal vorsichtig, wäre die Nachspielzeit ein bisschen länger gewesen, hätte man vielleicht auch nochmal ein bisschen ja hinten raus zittern müssen. Aber trotzdem finde ich, also, Ithen hat sich da sehr, sehr gut schon eingefunden, ist halt einfach eine absolute, also, ist als Stürmer vorne drin, passt super, glaube ich, auch einfach zu diesem Tunesystem. Und er hat natürlich jetzt einfach den Vorteil, er muss halt dahinter so ein bisschen gucken, welche Positionierung bekommt welcher Spieler. Ich glaube, Apple Camp, der noch so ein bisschen gucken muss, wo findet er sich da ein. Aber gerade mit Muslia, finde ich, haben sie da auch einfach nochmal einen richtig guten Transfer holen können, der da, glaube ich, auch einfach noch mit dieses spielerische reinbringt. Und da bin ich sehr gespannt, was wir da jetzt noch von Düsseldorf sehen können. Michi, hast du auch da irgendwie noch einen Take zur Fortuna?
Ich habe einen Take, dass die Fortuna mich irgendwie immer rätselnd hinterlässt. Also jedes Jahr denkt man sich immer auf den Kader schaut, ja, Wahnsinn, super Mannschaft, das kann gut gehen. Und jedes Jahr, dann ist man auch irgendwann getrieben bei der Bewertung dieser Mannschaft davon, dass sie eigentlich aussteigen müsste, dass sie eigentlich oben mitspielen müsste. Und dann sieht man manchmal Spiele, also sorry, um das Viertel reinzubringen. Letztes Jahr, Ende Februar war das Düsseldorf zu Hause gegen Fürth. Und ich dachte mir, wie kann man mit so einer guten Mannschaft einen so schlechten Fußball spielen? Da war dann die Tune damals auch wirklich sehr ernüchtert danach. Da hat Fürth gewonnen. Das war der letzte Aussatzsieg von Fürth im Februar in Düsseldorf. Und da dachte man damals schon, die werden auf keinen Fall mehr da oben mitspielen. Haben es dann ja doch noch gemacht, weil sie sich immer wieder fangen, weil sie auch die individuelle Klasse haben und weil Daniel Tune auch einfach ein sehr guter Trainer ist. Aber wenn man jedes Jahr sagt, die könnten eigentlich, sie machen es aber nicht, dann ist irgendwann auch so eine self-fulfilling prophecy. Die schaffen es ja eh nicht. Der Saisonstart hat dann manchen vielleicht darin bestätigt, aber ich sehe schon auch, wie er sagt, Cedric Ettenpasta sehr gut rein. Muslia war jetzt in Paderborn gut, ist das Tor das Zweite, war es glaube ich, war einfach auch sehr gut gemacht von Muslia. Also das sind individuell sehr gute Spieler, man hat sich sehr klug verstärkt. Also auch das wird eine Mannschaft sein, die ich in den Top 6 erwarte. Ob sie jetzt dann ganz klar oben wegmarschieren werden, weiß ich nicht. Wer macht das in der 2. Liga? Vermutlich keiner. Aber es ist schon auch eine Mannschaft, die auch da, die nicht bei drei Punkten stehen bleiben wird, sondern dass er mal so eine 20-fach, sagen wir mal 15-fachen wird, die dann doch eher weiter oben landen wird am Ende. Man soll sich, glaube ich, keine Sorgen um die Futura machen auch. Habe ich auch nach dem ersten Spiel gemacht und werde ich auch weiter nicht machen. Dafür ist der Kader einfach zu gut und da eine Tune zu gut, der Trainer.
Ja, da würde ich mitgehen. Ich würde sagen, wir werfen dann einmal einen Blick auf die beiden Absteiger, auf Kiel und Bochum. Ich würde mal sagen, die haben sich ihren Saisonstart ein bisschen anders vorgestellt, vorsichtig ausgedrückt. Beide bisher, jeder mit einem Sieg, also mit drei Punkten. Zwei Niederlagen. Kiel hat jetzt am Wochenende in Fürth gewonnen. Michi freut sich. Und Bochum am zweiten Spieltag gegen Elbersberg. Da muss man aber auch zu sagen, ein bisschen profitiert sicherlich auch von dem frühen Platzbeweis der Elbersberger. Bochum jetzt gegen Schalke verloren am Samstagabend. Muss man sagen, sagt glaube ich auch viel darüber, wie, ja wie, was Muslitsch in kurzer Zeit aus diesem Schalke-Team geformt hat. Also ja klar, dieses Kaiserslautern-Spiel, das war glaube ich für viele ein bisschen ernüchtert. Und man muss glaube ich auch einfach sagen, wir hatten schon mal ein bisschen angekündigt. Ich glaube, Schalke-Spiele unter Muslitsch werden keine spielerische Meisterleistung, aber sie bringen eben das auf den Platz, was Schalke so ein bisschen abhandengekommen ist. Das habe ich letztes Mal schon gesagt. Und das ist eben dieses, diese Giftigkeit auf dem Platz wieder. Dieses ganz große, in Anführungszeichen, Malocha-Fußball so ein bisschen. Und dann natürlich aber immer mit der spielerischen Klasse. Von dem Söller beispielsweise, Karamann und Co. Also da ist schon ordentlich Potenzial, trotzdem in der Mannschaft und Bochum. Ja, weiß ich nicht. Also wie gesagt, die Laune bei Bochum ist glaube ich weiterhin nicht so richtig gut. Also ich gehe auch noch mit. Ich bin immer noch nicht der festen Überzeugung, das mit Hacking weiterzumachen, wirklich so die richtige Idee war. Und Lisa möchte dazu gerne noch sagen.
Ja, ich glaube, es ist so ein bisschen floskelhaft fast, wenn man das sagt. Aber so die Absteiger sind nicht unbedingt automatisch die, die dann automatisch irgendwie wieder ganz oben sind, die es direkt wieder schaffen. Ich glaube, wir haben auch oft genug hier im Podcast schon gesagt, die 2. Liga ist so eng und teilweise so unvorhersehbar, dass ich nach den ersten drei Spieltagen dann auch gar nicht so ein hartes Urteil fällen wollen würde. Das eine oder andere Spiel, gerade wenn wir jetzt über Bochum sprechen, zu Kiel kann Michi vielleicht gleich noch zwei, drei Sätze mehr sagen in Sachen Fürth, aber auch das Bochum-Spiel jetzt am Wochenende gegen Schalke kann natürlich anders laufen und eine ganz andere Richtung bekommen, wenn man zum Beispiel diesen Elfer macht, dass dann ein Loris Karius den nicht so ganz gut getretenen Elfer auch rausholt. Ja, das passiert an einem Tag, aber auch so was könnte einem Spielen eine ganz andere Richtung geben und du hast das gerade schon angesprochen. Schalke ist jetzt auf so einer kleinen Positivwelle, würde ich es nennen. Also ich weiß gar nicht, wann ich zuletzt so wirklich viele positive Stimmungen und so einen kleinen Hype in dieser Bubble wahrgenommen habe, wie er jetzt gerade ist. Es freut mich persönlich sehr. Ich bin auch ein bisschen neidisch, was da quasi jetzt ein neuer Trainer auch so bei den Fans bewirkt und wie es da gerade läuft. Spielerisch ja keine Offenbarung und noch Luft nach oben, aber einfach so die Mentalität, die Leidenschaft, um zwei so Buzzwords reinzubringen, das stimmt halt gerade. Und dann zieht man solche Spieler halt auch gerade, wenn es dann Heimspiele sind. Jetzt mit der Bochumbrille draufgeguckt, ja, nicht der Stadt, den man sich irgendwie erhofft hat, aber würde ich mir jetzt auch erst mal noch ein paar Spieltage angucken, weil das auch so ein Spiel war, wo ich sage, das kann auch anders laufen, wenn einfach einzelne Situationen anders passieren. Aber ja, wird spannend. Also ich war nicht bei denjenigen, die gesagt haben, Bochum und Kiel gehen bestimmt direkt wieder hoch, weil das irgendwie zu einfach wäre, gerade in der 2. Liga, so wie sie sich auch die letzten Jahre gezeigt haben.
Ja, ich würde bei Bochum noch eine Haken, so eine Personalie. Wir haben es bei Robin Knoche, bei Nürnberg gesagt. Ich würde halt bei Bochum mal immer auf Kevin Vogt gucken, weil ich würde sagen, die Stütze, die er sein soll, also das funktioniert bisher auch noch nicht so ganz. Klar, er verschießt dann halt auch noch den Elfmeter. Man muss halt auch sagen, also ohne da jetzt zu viel reinten interpretieren zu wollen, aber das sah halt auch schon, also der war halt auch einfach nicht schlecht geschossen.
Das könnte man wirklich so sagen, ja.
Ich glaube, Simon Tirotta hat dazu bei Sky gesagt, ja niemals halb hoch. Also es gibt halt wirklich so eine goldene Regel, Elfmeter niemals halb hoch schießen. Das geht einfach nicht gut. Und man muss auch einfach sagen, also davon abgesehen, dass er den Elfmeter nicht reinmacht, ich finde ihn auch in der Abwehr bringt er da definitiv noch nicht die Stabilität, die er bringen sollte. Das ist auch nicht exklusiv meine Meinung. Das hatte, glaube ich, Annalena Olofsky, die ja auch im Rasenfunk für Bochum gerne mal unterwegs ist, auch geschrieben. Also da gibt es sicherlich noch Fragezeichen. Ich glaube jetzt auch nicht, dass sie– also keinen großen Grund zur Sorge. Aber man muss eben einfach sagen, jetzt Münster, Paderborn, Nürnberg. Also du hast immer so, wie gesagt, nach drei Spieltagen brauchen wir jetzt nicht groß anfangen mit, ja, das sind dankbare und undankbare Gegner. Das ist, wie gesagt, nicht klar formulierbar. Aber, ja, also sie sollten irgendwie so langsam mal ihren Weg in dieser Liga auch finden und halt trotzdem checken, dass sie halt in vielen Spielen als Favorit gelten, einfach weil sie Absteiger sind. Und da fehlt mir halt zum Teil noch ein bisschen was. Lass uns einmal ganz kurz noch auf Kiel blicken. Wie gesagt, jetzt entführt gewonnen. Ich habe, Michi und ich hatten beide das Vergnügen, sie über 90 Minuten zu sehen. Ich bin einen bisschen besseren Ausgang als du, Michi. Tut mir leid an der Stelle. Ich glaube, man könnte fast sagen, Kiel hat jetzt gegen Fürth geschafft, die Tore vorne zu machen und diese Effizienz mitzubringen, die sie eben gegen Bielfeld noch nicht drin hatten. Würdest du mir da zustimmen?
Ja, die Frage ist, ob sie effizient waren, aber wahrscheinlich gar nicht effizient genug, wenn man auf die Großchancen und auf die Expected Pulse schaut. Das spricht für Kiel, dass sie sich die Chancen herausgespielt haben. Das spricht nicht für Fürth, dass sie 3,6, 3,7 Expected Goals in einem Heimspiel zuzulassen. Puh, in einem Ausschussspiel sich zu erspielen, okay. Das hat auch dazu gepasst. Ich fand die Kieler gut, sie waren griffig. Man hat auch bei manchen gesehen, dass es die Bundesliga was gebracht hat. Sie haben sich auch klug verstärkt. Insgesamt die Geschwindigkeit bei manchen Spielern. Ich fand Ter Kielsen in dem Spiel sehr gut, nicht nur wegen des Tores. Auch Knudsen im Mittelfeld, Robert Wagner. Ich habe ihn sehr vermisst. In Fürth haben wir wieder gesehen, warum ich ihn vermisse. Eine gute Verpflichtung für die Sechs. Insgesamt ein sehr reifer Auftritt. Tolkien hat das 2-0 gemacht. Auch das Super-Spiel fand ich. Da hat man nicht gesehen, dass da eine Mannschaft spielt, die in den letzten zwei Spielen zweimal verloren hatte in der zweiten Liga. Sie sind ja nicht untergegangen in den beiden Spielen, sondern die waren beide unglücklich in den Dialagen. Vor allem am ersten Spieltag. Klar, gegen Bielefeld kann jeder mal verlieren, das ist klar. Aber bei euch denke ich, will ich mir gar keine Sorgen machen. Da geht auch das Gleiche wie bei Fortuna Düsseldorf mit Marcel Rapp einfach einen sehr guten Trainer. Das ist in der Bundesliga schon der Fußball sah sehr gut aus. Sie haben wieder sehr viele Bausteine, um weiterhin guten Fußball zu spielen. Sie haben mit Phil Harris einen super Stürmer vorne drin, der zwar kein Tor jetzt gemacht hat, wird aber trotzdem auch wieder gefährlich sein in mehreren Situationen. Sie haben ein gutes Mittelfeld. Sie haben im Tor gewechselt. Jonas Krumrei ist da jetzt ja im Tor, also vielleicht für manchen etwas überraschend. Fand ich aber auch in dem Spiel sehr gut, sehr sicher. Also, da sind eben sehr viele Baustände da, um ein stabiles Fundament erst mal zu bauen und daraus dann auch wieder was Gutes zusammenzubauen. Also, mich haben sie überzeugt in diesem Spiel. Auch da kann man jetzt sagen, sie steigen auf jeden Fall wieder auf, aber würde ich auch mal eher in die obere Tabellenhefte setzen, auch wenn sie da momentan noch eher weiter unten stehen. Aber das hat mich einfach in allem– sie waren dann defensiv in der zweiten Halbzeit auch gut gestanden, haben sehr wenig zugelassen, haben das kompakt verteidigt. Also das war einfach rundum gelungener Auftritt. Und das ist ja für einen Bundesliga-Absteiger, der sich erst mal fangen muss in so einer Liga, dann nach zwei Spieltagen, wo man dann gerne mit dem viel zitierten Rücken zur Wand steht, schon ein sehr guter Auftritt von Heusten Kiel überführt. Sprechen wir vielleicht mal anders mal das.
Michi möchte nicht.
Nein, ich möchte heute nicht sprechen. Hört ihr für den Flachpass?
Das solltet ihr auf jeden Fall sowieso machen. Zu Kiel noch eine Sache, das wird auch im Forum geschrieben. Das Fragezeichen ist rund um die Innenverteidigung noch, weil es da eben noch überhaupt keine feste Besetzung gibt. Sicherlich auch ein bisschen damit zu tun, dass Komenda eben noch verletzt ist. Aber da muss man auch sagen, also das hat man gegen Bielenfeld einfach gesehen. Dieses hinten raus spielen, das funktioniert halt noch nicht so ganz, weil da glaube ich einfach zum Teil die die altbewährten Automatismen noch nicht so da sind. Ist ja auch irgendwie klar, wenn du immer wieder wechselt. Aber deshalb war man zum Beispiel gegen Bielenfeld, da glaube ich, auch relativ anfällig. Aber generell würde ich da auf jeden Fall mitgehen. Also die spielen guten Fußball. Das ist, die sind schon in vielen Bereichen gut dabei. Und sie haben halt so eine gewisse Resilienz durch die, auch nur durch dieses eine Jahr Bundesliga, aber einfach mitgebracht. Und das ist schon durchaus gut für sie. Also man muss ja einfach sagen, Kiel ist dann auch einfach nicht der klassische Absteiger, weil man einfach mehr 2. Liga in den letzten Jahren gespielt hat als Bundesliga. Und ich glaube, vielleicht fehlt es ihnen deshalb auch nicht so wahnsinnig schwer, sich dann auch wieder in dieser Liga einzufinden, auch wenn man eben Anfangsschwierigkeiten hatte. Wir schauen noch da einmal gerade drauf, was da jetzt als Nächstes ansteht.
Ich gehe ganz kurz rein dazwischen. Dokumenta hat jetzt wieder mitgespielt.
Ah ja, sorry.
Also der war verletzt, das war ja auch ein Thema vor dem Spiel. Da hat man auch die PK von Marcel Rapp angeschaut und hat jetzt auch zum ersten Mal wieder mitgespielt. Also auch der Baustein ist dann wieder da, der altbewährte Kieler Baustein. Insofern geht es wahrscheinlich auch da aufwärts und man wird vermutlich nicht jedes Spiel jetzt wieder eine andere Dreiecke sehen, sondern kann sich da auch finden. Und untermauert unsere These, dass Heustern Kiel vermutlich relativ schnell da unten rauskommen wird.
Genau, man hat noch als Zusatz natürlich noch im DFB-Pokal beim FC Homburg gewonnen. Ich glaube, ohne viel Trarat, das kann man glaube ich noch dazu sagen. Also es war jetzt kein aufregendes Spiel, sagen wir mal so. Und jetzt kommt eben als nächstes Hannover. Da bin ich tatsächlich sehr gespannt drauf auf diesen Smash-Up-Tits gegen Rapp. Das könnte glaube ich durchaus eine interessante Partie Samstag 13 Uhr werden und nach der Länderspielpause geht es dann nach Schalke. Da gibt es auch ein Wiedersehen unter anderem zwischen Finn Porat und seinem alten Verein direkt wieder und dann eben Sonntag darauf gegen Karlsruhe. Also ja, ich gehe da mit eurer Einschätzung mit. Ich glaube auch bei Kiel vor allem sehe ich ehrlich gesagt ein paar mehr Ansätze generell im Spiel. Aber auch, dass man sich da durchaus auch in die Top-Mannschaften da noch vorarbeiten könnte. Lass uns von den Absteigern zu den Aussteigern in diese Liga noch gehen. Dresden, die konnten nämlich gestern den ersten Saisongesieg gegen na klar Bielefeld einfahren. Und da muss man sagen, trotz der Verletzung von Christoph Daferner und Vincent Fermet, den hatte man ja noch aus Düsseldorf geholt. Dank, man hat in der 108. Minute der Nachspielzeit oder so, dank einem absoluten Traumtor von– nee, gar nicht wahr, das war die 98. Minute, ist auch egal– absolutes Traumtor von Luca Hermann. Das hat sich ja ungefähr 408. Minute. Man muss zu Dresden sagen, Michi hat sie ja auch schon gesehen, das war alles geplant, hatten ja auch durchaus gute Ansätze bisher. Einige Tore gefallen, die Abwehr ein bisschen vorgewählt zuletzt und ja auch im Pokal, muss man sagen, ein bisschen unglücklich vielleicht hinten raus, gegen Mainz rausgeflogen, unter anderem, weil man aber bisher vielleicht auch offensiv die Fehler der Defensive nicht ausgleichen konnte, kann man vielleicht zu sagen. Man muss sagen, gerade in den ersten 45 Minuten gestern war das eine richtig, richtig gute Leistung von Dynamo, die waren körperlich da, die waren kämpferisch da und eben auch spielerisch, das soll nicht untergehen. Also sie sind durchaus auch jetzt in der 2. Liga angekommen. Und ich muss ja sagen, von sehr, sehr vielen Leuten ja auch als Absteiger getippt, unter anderem auch von mir, glaube ich. Was ich auch irgendwie, ja, sie zeigen durchaus, dass man da vielleicht nicht rein gehören möchte und da vielleicht einfach ein bisschen unter dem Radar fliegt, weil Bielefeld der Mitaufsteiger war und man von denen einfach auch mehr gesehen hat in den letzten Wochen und Monaten. Aber Michi, vielleicht auch einmal kurz deine Einschätzung, weil du sie ja gegen Fürth auch gesehen hast.
Ich habe sie ja direkt am ersten Spieltag gesehen und das ging ja dann maximal schlecht los für so einen Aufsteiger, dass man schon nach 28 Sekunden, glaube ich, war. Es ist 0-1 kassiert im Spiel. Also für Fürth war das damals gut, weil man diese Wucht, die einen Aufsteiger ja entwickelt, das waren, glaube ich, auch vier bis fünftausend Dresdnerinnen und Dresdner da. Insofern, da kann man diese Wucht schon ein bisschen bremsen, die einem dann entgegenkommt. Aber ich fand trotzdem, dass sie auch für einen Aufsteiger da schon gute Automatismen gezeigt haben, dass sie guten Fußball gespielt haben. Wie du gerade schon angedeutet hast, Eva, war es dann eher die Defensive, warum sie in Fürth dann verloren haben. Sie haben jetzt zwei Tore geschossen auswärts, das ist erstmal nicht schlecht als Aufsteiger. Haben aber halt drei kassiert gegen Fürth. Und vor allem, wer das Tor gesehen hat von Futtkoi, wird dadurch durch drei Mann einfach durchspaziert. Das hat er jetzt gegen Kiel genauso versucht. Und dann ist er einfach am ersten Gegenspiel abgeprallt. Also da muss auch die Verteidigung dann ankommen. Und ich glaube auch, dass sie, wenn sie sich das Schwert hinterlegt, wenn sie lang gegen den Abstieg spielen, wenn sie vielleicht sogar absteigen, das würde ich jetzt nicht sagen. Aber ich habe sie auch dahin getippt, zumindest mal, wenn sie denn absteigen würden, dann vermutlich eher aufgrund der Defensive, nicht aufgrund der spielerischen Komponente und der Offensivpower, die sie entwickeln können. Der Ferner auch in Fürth schon gefährlich gewesen. Jetzt hast du gesagt, verletzt, aber trotzdem auch ein guter Stürmer, der offenbar ja auch nur in Dresden funktioniert. Und sie müssen halt die Defensive in den Griff bekommen. Wenn das klappt, dann können sie da auch lang wahrscheinlich dann auch um den Klassen mitspielen. Also das sehe ich auf keinen Fall schwarz, auch wenn der Saisonstand nicht so gut war. Aber ich habe tatsächlich nur bei der Defensive da Bauchschmerzen.
Ja, würde ich komplett mitgehen. Michi, der Ferner hast du gerade angesprochen, ist für mich dann immer so klassischer Fall von, ich sitze in der Redaktion und es passiert irgendwie was, der Ferner macht ein Tor, dass ich dann sage, auch ein Ex-Nürnberger, der bei uns nicht so funktioniert hat, aber da passt er rein und da läuft. Deshalb, das ist glaube ich auch ein Spieler, sobald der wieder zurück ist, hat man da vorne eine offensive Wucht und wird da auch das ein oder andere nach vorne sehen können. Also ich glaube jetzt tatsächlich auch gegen Bielefeld, ich will jetzt nicht sagen glücklich, das ist ein bisschen vielleicht zu negativ, aber ein Stück weit schon auch glücklich, dass man natürlich so ein Traumtor dann in der 98. glaube ich, was macht, war dann für Bielefeld zu zählen, natürlich ehrlicherweise auch deutlich schwerer. Dagegen zu halten und dann ist es halt einfach mal so eine Szene, die ich will jetzt nicht sagen einmal im Jahr so passiert, aber viel öfter vermutlich nicht, dass man den dann auch so trifft und so reinmacht. Und das Spiel dann halt noch so dreht, ist so ein bisschen das Glück des Tüchtigen vielleicht, dass man da als Dresden dann auch sagt, okay, man zieht so ein Spiel. Aber bin auch gespannt, was da noch kommt. Also jetzt so von den ersten Eindrücken würde ich auch nicht sagen, dass sie wie so ein klarer Absteiger aussehen oder sich präsentiert hätten. Obwohl ich sie auch getippt habe. Aber ich glaube, so ein bisschen das, was du gerade auch angerissen hattest, Eva, so sind ein bisschen unterm Radar gewesen. Und der Hype um Bielefeld war halt sehr, sehr groß. Und man hat da sehr, sehr viel mitbekommen, dass das so ein bisschen der Kontrast an der Stelle, glaube ich, einfach ist, dass man von Dresden nicht so viel vielleicht gesehen oder gehört hat, von der großen Fanszene und krassen Kurios, vielleicht an der einen oder anderen Stelle abgesehen.
Ja, ich würde noch dazu ergänzen, ich muss auch einfach sagen, Dynamo hat das in Überzahl sehr, sehr gut gemacht. Also Dianne Bielefeld auch wirklich tief in die eigene Hälfte gepresst, kaum Chance zum Kontern gegeben. Also ich meine, im Endeffekt hätte, glaube ich, Marvin Melem hätte das Ding nicht geführt, zehn Meter neben das Tor gesetzt. Auch noch, also gab es halt diesen einen Moment, aber ich meine, es ist halt keine Selbstverständlichkeit, dass man in Überzahl dann doch, also ich habe es eben einmal angesprochen, Düsseldorf hatte durchaus Probleme gegen Paderborn. Wir erinnern uns an den ersten Spieltag Magdeburg in Überzahl gegen Braunschweig, wo sie das am Ende noch verlieren. Also es ist eben nicht selbstverständlich und Dynamo hat das wirklich sehr, sehr gut gemacht. Die waren taktisch einfach richtig gut eingestellt. Thomas Stamm macht das einfach gut da, der passt da irgendwie auch einfach zu Dresden. Und da bin ich tatsächlich sehr gespannt. Also ich hatte aber das Gefühl, es war gar nicht so schlecht, dass sie eben nicht diesen klassischen Stürmer vorne drin hatten. Also man muss ja auch sagen, Stefan Kutschke ist halt auch weiterhin einfach nur Ergänzungsspieler. Den bringst du halt hin rein. Der ist halt einfach mal abgesehen, dass man ihn persönlich durchaus kritisieren kann, was er so neben dem Spielfeld macht. Es ist natürlich trotzdem irgendwie so eine Geschichte, wo man gut sagen kann, Stammer hat auf jeden Fall auch einen guten Plan ohne Stürmer und er schien fast etwas besser zu funktionieren als mit Stürmer. Einfach weil man sich so taktisch vielleicht ein bisschen anders orientieren konnte. Auch da einmal kurz, also wie gesagt, man ist im Pokal gegen die Mainzer rausgeflogen und hat jetzt eben als nächstes Sonntag 13.30 gegen Schalke. Das wird auf jeden Fall, glaube ich, rein fan-technisch auf jeden Fall eine absolute Brecherpartie. Dann Sonntag die Woche drauf bzw. zwei Wochen später nach der Länderspielpause in Elbersberg und dann nochmal sonntags gegen Hannover 96. Das sind eben die Partien und dann schauen wir einmal ganz kurz auch auf Bielefeld. Klar, die nach zwei Siegen in der Liga gingen, ein bisschen davon Kiel und die Pokalsieg gegen Werder. Ja, mit der ersten Niederlage, sogar der ersten Liganiederlage seit dem 8. März 2025. Und ich glaube, ich war der ersten Heimniederlage seit Februar oder so. Es war das hundertste Spiel von Mitch Kniart und ich muss das einmal kurz sagen. Es gab in 120 Jahren Vereinsgeschichte mit Daten, mit denen man wirklich arbeiten kann. Das hat man so in den 70er-Jahren ungefähr nur vier Trainer folgen geschafft. Das hier jemand mit mehr und das war Ernst Middendorf das erste Mal von 1988 bis 1990. Da hatte er 102 Spiele. Hans Wendland 113 Spiele von 1966 bis 1969 und dann Benno Möhlmann 119 von 2000 bis 2004. Und nochmal Middendorf, klar, der Ernst 143 Spiele von 1994 bis 1998. Das sagt auch sehr viel darüber hinaus. Kontinuität auf dem Trainerposten ist Lava, war Amina, von daher freue ich mich umso sehr. Man muss auch dazu sagen, dass die wurden geehrt vor Spielbeginn und dann gab es auch wieder die obligatorischen Kniatrausrufe. Das wurde dann ein bisschen der Spiel schon letzte Saison umgedreht, dass man so ein bisschen, weil er selber auch gesagt hat, Kniatraus war eben sein Doppelname. Er findet selber glaube ich auch ganz lustig. Aber das Spiel hätte er sicherlich gerne auch gewonnen. War ehrlich gesagt nichts, wie gesagt, über weite Strecken. Man muss sagen, Marvin Melem, ja schon so einer der Königstransfers bisher für Bielefeld, der passt noch nicht so ganz ins System. Generell, das System hat gestern auch einfach nicht funktioniert. Also das hat keiner so richtig verstanden. Aber man muss jetzt auch sagen, Melem bekommt jetzt auf seiner Position eben wieder Konkurrenz, denn Marius Wöhrl ist zurück. Also der wurde vor Anführung gefeiert, als wäre es, weiß ich nicht, ein Siegtor oder so. Also das war irgendwie schon ganz schön zu sehen. Aber generell muss man glaube ich einfach sagen, ich hoffe einfach, wir sehen mehr von die Bielefeld aus der letzten Saison als vor zwei. Da ist man nämlich auch mit einem Pokalsieg und einem Derbysieg damals in die Saison gestartet. Und wir wissen alle, dass es hinterher ein Pfostenschuss gegen Halle brauchte oder der Hallenser, um in der Liga zu bleiben. Aber generell glaube ich, ich bin jetzt einfach mal froh, dass wir mal wieder verloren haben. Und wir können jetzt auch, also es war anstrengend auch jetzt irgendwann mal. Ich wusste nicht, wann passiert. Ich hätte es gerne nicht gegen Dresden gemacht, sage ich auch ganz ehrlich.
Bist du wirklich froh, dass der Hype jetzt so ein bisschen gestoppt ist, was jetzt die Niederlage angeht? Wirklich, ich war immer ein bisschen neidisch die letzten Wochen und Monate und dachte mir, Bielefeld-Fan, das müsste eigentlich das sein, was gerade mit am meisten Bock macht. Nicht nur wegen Aufstieg, Fokalfinale, auch so die Stimmung rund um den Verein, dass ich jetzt gedacht hätte, ja okay, es ist ein kleiner Dämpfer, aber weiter geht's. Und das immer noch sehr, sehr positiv bewerten würde, so aus der nicht-Bielefeld-Fanbrille, aber interessierter Beobachter-Fanbrille. War dir der Hype schon ein bisschen zu viel an der Stelle jetzt in den letzten Wochen?
Ja, ich glaube einfach, weil, also man muss einfach sagen, solche Hypes ziehen einfach Leute an, die man vielleicht auch einfach, also, die dann auf einmal alle da sind. Ich habe es dir in der ersten Folge angesprochen, was halt momentan dahinter steckt, hinter diesem Hype. Ich check auch, wenn das irgendwann allen anderen Fans auf den Keks geht, muss ich auch ganz ehrlich sagen. Ich glaube, also, ich finde diese Diskussion, wer leidet am meisten, sowieso immer so ein bisschen schwachsinnig, weil es ist einfach subjektiv. Ich verstehe jeden Club-Fan, der sagt, wir haben die meiste Scheiße ehrlich gesagt mitgenommen. Frag mal bei MSV Duisburg oder 1860 München nach. Also, das ist halt sowieso subjektiv. Ja, ich glaube, ich bin ganz froh, dass es jetzt passiert ist mit der Niederlage. Dann hat man eben auch die Chance, das jetzt ganz gut einzuordnen. Und es geht jetzt eben am Samstag gegen Eintracht Braunschweig weiter. Aber generell macht es trotzdem Spaß, Bielefeld-Fans zu sein. Aber ganz liebe Grüße an die Leute, die dann direkt nach dem Gegentor gestern das Stadion verlassen hat. Das Spiel dauert so lange, bis der Schiedsrichter abfreut.
Okay, das ist natürlich lost.
Ja, und über die Schiedsrichterleistung habe ich noch ehrlich gesagt gar keinen Bock mehr zu diskutieren. Ich sage nur noch mal, wenn so ein VAR-Check drei Minuten dauert und dann ist nicht so ganz klar, was der Schiedsrichter mit seiner Geste meint, das werden wir dann ja bald geklärt haben. Auch das Flächen, beziehungsweise auch in der 2. Liga überall, glaube ich jetzt, auch die, ich glaube, nach der Länderspielpause die Stadion ansagen, bei allen 2. Ligisten starten, wenn ich da richtig informiert bin. Aber gut, zu viel dazu. Genau Bielefeld jetzt eben gegen Braunschweig und dann nach der Länderspielpause. Da brauche ich, glaube ich, sogar keinen Zettel, um das rauszufinden. Geht es erst gegen Magdeburg am Freitagabend und dann kommt die Spielvereinigung und führt auf die Alm. Ein Spiel, das ich leider verpassen werde. Das tut mir sehr leid.
Ich nicht. Ob es mir dann leid tut, werde ich danach sehen. Aber ich werde da sein. Schauen wir mal. Ist auch wieder klar. Dann werde ich einmal nach Bielefeld kommen in 4 Jahren. Dann bist du dich da, Eva.
Das ist natürlich auch der größte Zufall. Ja, ja. Alles mit Absicht. Eine ganz kleine Sache. Ich wollte eigentlich hier, da habe ich mich selber versprochen, und zwar wollte ich so ein bisschen Sachen neben dem Platz hier noch einbringen. Einmal bei Bielefeld einfach, weil ich weiß, da gibt es ein bisschen Diskussionen, weil der Stadionsprecher der Bielefelder Damen ja durchaus aufgefallen ist wegen, ja, sagen wir mal, AfD nahen Äußerungen und eben auch social media technisch. Und da muss man sagen, ist es manchmal vielleicht auch ein Nachteil, dass es jetzt eben diesen Hype gibt, weil sowas vielleicht dann manchmal ein bisschen untergeht. Aber da kann man schon sicher sein, das wird von den Fans auch ganz gut angesprochen, dass eben das nicht weitergeht. Aber man muss da leider einfach sagen, da ist eben auch der Fußball der Frauen. Gerade dann, wenn es da eben nur Regionalliga, also 3. Liga ist, dann tatsächlich, weil eben viel auf ehrenamtlicher Basis passiert, ja, geht dann immer so ein bisschen unter, leider. Aber so viel dazu noch. Gut. Dann lass uns auf zwei Teams gucken, die bei ganz, ganz vielen tatsächlich als Abstiegskandidaten gelten oder gegolten haben. Und das sind Braunschweig und Elversberg. Und da muss man sagen, die beide mit einem guten Start in die Saison. Also Braunschweig, also beide sechs Punkte. Und dazu muss man sagen, wenn ich richtig nachgeguckt hatte, hat Eintrott Braunschweig sechs Punkte letztes Jahr erst nach dem Derbysieg gegen Hannover im Oktober 2024. Nee, doch 2024 gehabt. Wow. Es ist Montag. Naja, morgen. Genau. Und generell, also Braunschweig, die hatten ja ein Wochenende mehr Pause, weil ihr Gegner, der VfB Stuttgart im DFB Pokal, den Supercup gespielt haben. Ich weiß, ich wiederhole mich da. Ich finde das ehrlich gesagt immer noch ein Unding, dass am Ende des Tages die unterklassigen Vereine darunter leiden müssen, in Anführungszeichen, und eben dann eine englische Woche haben. Ja, sehe ich irgendwie immer noch nicht so als ganz fair an, aber gut. Genau, Braunschweig jetzt eben in einer 2-0-Niederlage gegen Karlsruhe. Die haben das Spielfreie Wochenende genutzt, um nochmal so ein Mini-Trainingslager zu machen, was ein bisschen komisch klingt nach zwei Siegen und nach zwei Spieltagen. Aber da ging es, glaube ich, Heiner Backhaus vor allem um das Spiel mit dem Ball. Ja, war jetzt nicht so gut gegen Karlsruhe, kann man glaube ich sagen. Aber ich glaube, da, also in Braunschweig behält man da die Ruhe. Das war ja trotzdem auch alles gut soweit. Ja, also Michi, du hast ja Braunschweig auch gesehen. Er hebt schon hier die Hand. Was hast du zu Braunschweig zu sagen?
Ich habe Braunschweig gesehen, habe sie in den letzten Jahren noch öfter gesehen und fand sie das tatsächlich, das war ja vor zwei Wochen, drei Wochen, ich weiß gar nicht mehr, also auf jeden Fall vor einigen Tagen, erst, dass sie da tatsächlich besser aussahen insgesamt, als sie es in den letzten Jahren getan haben. Ich muss auch sagen, die haben da einfach auch ein paar ganz gute Transfers getätigt für das Spiel mit dem Ball Lino Tempelmann, Robin Heuser, das sah einfach gut aus. Sie haben dafür Rayan Philipp verloren, dafür war Erincani Adimci im Spiel gegen Fürth, fand ich gut. Also es hat offensiv schon besser ausgesehen. Weshalb ich aber immer noch ein bisschen Bauchschmerzen habe, also dieser Sieg gegen Fürth, da lagen sie auch erst mal hinten und dann haben sie mit zwei relativ schnellen Angriffen, bei der die Fürther Defensive, die ja gerade schon wieder die 2 schlechteste in der Liga ist, nicht gut aussah, da 2 Tore gemacht. Sie sind aber in der zweiten Halbzeit noch ganz schön geschwommen, haben dann für viel den Ball gegeben, eigentlich fast schon zu viel, finde ich dafür, dass man sich auch spielerisch verbessern will in einem Heimspiel. Sie haben das Spiel dann aber trotzdem spät in Ausgleich noch gewonnen mit einer Willensleistung. Da ist Heiner Backhaus natürlich dann sehr glücklich gewesen. Der hat schon vor dem Spiel sehr viel von Herz gesprochen und von, dass man immer alles geben muss. Ich kenne das auch aus Furt von dem Trainer. Wenn man immer von alles geben und sehr viel Herzblut und Gier und Leidenschaft und Kämpfe und so weiter spricht, irgendwann nutzt sich das ab. Ich bin gespannt, wann sich das abnutzt bei Braunschweig. Ich sehe bei ihnen weitaus weniger Schwarze als in der letzten Saison. Das ist aber auch nicht schwer. Das habt ihr auch in der Vorschau schon ein bisschen besprochen. Sie sind halt mit Acht und Krach irgendwie drin geblieben, was auch daran lag, dass der erste Zerbrückende in der Relegation auch nicht wirklich gut war in den Spielen. Man ist dann drin geblieben, das ist das Wichtigste.
Das hast du freundlich ausgedrückt.
Ja, ich bin ein freundlicher Mensch tendenziell. Da hat man schon darauf reagiert. Es gab ja auch schon diese Wutrede von Sven Köhler, der der neue Kapitän jetzt auch ist in Braunschweig. Nach dem Relegationsspiel, wenn man so weitermacht wie in der letzten Saison, dann wird man irgendwann absteigen. Hat offenbar nicht für so viel Freude im Umfeld des Vereins gesorgt. Ich habe auch ein bisschen den Podcast der Kollegen, ein bisschen Werbeblock, Studio Blau-Gelb, da kann man sich gerne mal anhören. Da waren Sven Köhler und Ron Torbenhoffmann bei einem Live-Podcast zu Gast auch sehr erfrischend. Köhler, neuer Kapitän, nachdem man Eisen-Ermin verabschiedet hat. Er war ein sehr wichtiger Spieler, Ermin Bicakčić in der letzten Saison. Da hat man auch den Umbruch gewagt mit einem neuen Trainer, Heiner Bakos, der ja in Aachen davor war. Man hat da viel versucht umzudrehen, dafür sind die sechs Punkte jetzt schon mal sehr gut. Aber ich bleibe dabei, dass das Eintracht-Branche trotzdem weit hinten mitspielen wird, weil der Kader individuell zwar besser ist als der letzte Saison, aber noch weit nicht so gut ist wie viele andere Mannschaften. Und ich auch vom Spiel mit dem Ball jetzt bislang nicht so überzeugt war von dem, was ich gesehen habe. Der erste Sieg gegen Magdeburg war ja auch glücklich. Da hat man dann mit einem Schuss aus 40 Metern, ich weiß nicht, ich habe die, ich habe sich abgemessen. Aber man hat da auf jeden Fall mit einem Fernschuss dann das 1-0 gemacht gegen Magdeburger, die jetzt auch im ersten Spiel keinen Titzahura-Fußball gespielt haben. Also das waren wichtige Punkte, die muss man holen. Die sechs Punkte hat man jetzt schon mal. Die helfen einem vielleicht am Ende, wenn es dann auf wenige Punkte ankommt. Aber ich würde mir das auch gerne, wie Lisa vorhin mal gesagt hat, bei Braunschweig auch noch ein paar Wochen anschauen, um dann ein abschließendes Urteil zu fällen. Aber sie haben jetzt schon mal die Punkte und dann kann man damit auch leichter arbeiten. Das ist schon mal sehr gut für alle Braunschweigerinnen und Braunschweiger.
Ja und ich finde trotz Einmalt auch einfach ein gutes Zeichen von Backhaus, dass man eben gesagt hat, ne auch noch zwei Spieltage nochmal als ein Fokus auf das Spiel mit dem Ball legen. Also das fand ich auch schon irgendwie, dass man da direkt sagt, ne wir erkennen unsere Probleme schon. Gut man muss auch gleichzeitig immer sagen, gut das habt ihr dann in der Vorbereitung gemacht. Also die ist dann ja auch nicht so lange. Ne aber, also generell bin ich sehr, sehr gespannt. Also morgen Abend, 20.45 Uhr, ja Montag logischerweise, wann ihr mir ja auch diesen Podcast hört, geht es dann eben gegen Stuttgart im Pokal. Und da bin ich schon, ja also ich bin schon gespannt. Also einfach auch nach diesem ersten Spiel der Stuttgarter, das mich doch durchaus, das könnt ihr natürlich alles in der Rasenfunk-Besprechung nachhören zu diesem ersten Spieltag. Bin ich schon gespannt, was eintragt, weil sie müssen ja den Ball in diesem Spiel einfach nicht haben. Also das ist ja schon mal klar, dass Stuttgart da eben das Spiel machen muss. Und da bin ich sehr gespannt, was wir da von Eintracht Braunschweig sehen.
Das war schon fast ein perfekter Werbeteaser, du morgen im Ersten natürlich oder in der ARD Mediathek, um natürlich auch meinem Auftrag nachzukommen. Ich bin gespannt, yes.
Nur als Vollständigkeit halber natürlich am Mittwoch dann das Spiel zwischen Bayern München und Wiesbaden. Am Mittwochabend in Wiesbaden.
Beide Kollegen im ZDF.
So, danke schön. Juhu an der Stelle. Lass uns noch kurz auf die SV Elbersberg gucken, weil ich würde sagen, die hat uns bisher auch ganz gut überrascht. Ich glaube, bei der waren sehr viele auch der Überzeugung. Ohne Horst Steffen und ohne die Spieler, die Elbersberg ausgemacht haben, wird das nix. Wir waren nach dem Sieg gegen Nürnberg noch ein wenig verhalten. Dann gab es eben diese durchaus unglückliche Niederlage gegen Bochum. Hatte aber sicherlich viel mit zu tun mit dem frühesten Platzverweis, glaube ich, zumindest in der 2. Liga, wenn ich das richtig gesehen habe. Aber jetzt zum Beispiel gegen den FCK am Freitagabend. Zwar auch wieder ein Last-Minute-Tor, aber da muss man sagen hoch verdient. Die haben richtig, richtig guten Fußball über weite Strecken gegen Kaiserslautern gespielt. Man muss sagen, bisher ein interessanter Start von Elbersberg. Sie fliegen natürlich weiterhin so ein bisschen unterm Radar bzw. kommen, glaube ich, ganz gut klar mit dieser Underdog-Krolle, die sie trotz der guten letzten Saison fahren.
Ich glaube, da hast du schon was Totalbares gesagt an der Stelle. Die fühlen sich wohl damit, dass sie gerade nicht so gehypt sind, dass sie so ein bisschen unterm Radar fliegen, dass keiner so Erwartungen irgendwie hat, weil man eben weiß, okay, viele Spieler verloren, Trainer weg. Und das ist eher so eine, mal gucken, wie es wird dieses Jahr. Ich habe sie tatsächlich auch als Absteiger getippt, weil ich nicht so überzeugt war, ob man so einen großen Umbruch in dieser sehr, sehr engen Liga so auffangen kann. Der erste Spieltag gegen Nürnberg hatten wir ja gerade schon so ein bisschen angerissen. Da habe ich jetzt ehrlicherweise auch noch nicht so viel gesehen, dass ich sagen würde, naja, okay, die bleiben in der Liga und das könnte was werden. War aber halt auch wirklich der erste Spieltag. Deswegen bin ich total gespannt, wie sich das entwickelt. Jetzt am Freitag gegen Kaiserslautern habe ich gefühlt auch nur von Lautern-Fans, so aus meinem persönlichen Umfeld gehört, die frustriert waren, dass es nicht so lief, was so ein bisschen auch an der Leistung von Lautern selbst lag. Ich bin aber total gespannt und glaube, aus Elbersberger Sicht kann man einfach so froh sein, dass es so losging, wie es losging. Ich würde happy sein, dass man diese sechs Punkte jetzt schon im Sack hat und erst mal deutlich besser dasteht, als man das vielleicht auch selber so eingeschätzt hätte. Also wenn man so die ersten Spiele guckt, so gegen wen muss man ran, glaube ich macht sich ja schon immer so ein Gefühl breit, so ist das machbar oder wird es eher schwer. Und da hätte ich jetzt auch nicht unbedingt aus Elbersberger Sicht getippt, dass man da mit sechs Punkten ehrlicherweise dasteht. Deswegen das wird für mich so ein Club ehrlicherweise, wo ich gespannt bin, ob das so weitergeht. Also hat mich positiv überrascht, zumindest mit Blick auf die Zähler, die man jetzt schon gesammelt hat.
Ich habe sie auch auf Platz 16 getippt, bilde ich mir ein. Aber das lag auch ein bisschen daran an den Transverse. Wenn man zu den ersten Spieltagen anschaut, ist es wahrscheinlich nicht mehr dieser aufregende Fußball mit Aslani und Co., der jeden Spieltag denkt, Wahnsinn, was die da abliefern. Aber es wirkt insgesamt sehr solide. Auch die Verbindungen sind wieder sehr klug. Ich finde immer noch Ole Burg, der Manager der Elvesberger, einen der besten der 2. Liga, auch immer noch sehr unterschätzt. Wenn andere Vereine nach Sportdirektoren oder Sportgeschäftsführern schauen, sollten sie auch mal in Saarland schauen, auch wenn es vielleicht ein weiter Weg ist dorthin. Aber der macht einfach seit Jahren extrem gute Arbeit. Auch das Trainer-Scouting, mit dem Vincent Wagner auch sehr aufwendig gescoutet. Vincent Wagner ist plötzlich auch ein anderer Mensch. Ich habe mich am Freitag bei SkyMet gewundert. Der Trainer bei Interviews war Vincent Wagner, der ja optisch jetzt ganz anders aussieht. Wer es nicht gesehen hat, schaut es euch an. Aber auch der Bamba Sekundär hat mir letztes Jahr schon sehr gut gefallen beim KSC. Er hat dann noch mal Schritte nach vorne gemacht, ist jetzt auch wieder gut gewesen im letzten Spiel. Amara Kondy ist auch solider Zweitligaspieler. Lukas Petkoff findet sich dort immer besser zurecht als Spieler. Schnellbacher ist immer noch da, hat eben wieder ein Tor gemacht. Das ist auch eine der letzten verbliebenen in dieser ganz erfolgreichen Everspiker-Mannschaft. Dafür, dass man seinen Kapitän verloren hat, den Trainer verloren hat, den Aufstiegstrainer, den Wundermacher fast schon, und dann auch noch die besten Talente verloren hat, sind sechs Punkte jetzt schon mal sehr gut zum Auftakt. Vermutlich werden sie nicht wieder Relegation spielen. Aber das hat schon mal jetzt ein bisschen Hoffnung gemacht, dass man auf jeden Fall vielleicht so unbedarfte Beobachter wie mich dann lügen strafen kann, dass man auch in diesem Jahr nicht gegen den Abstieg spielen wird. Aber auch da ist vielleicht für einen Urteil noch zu früh. Aber man hat trotzdem klug gemacht. Und ich glaube einfach, dass man in vielen Spielen weiterhin solide bis unangenehm für die Gegner sein wird. Und dann reicht es in der 2. Liga ja oftmals schon. Wenn man nach Standards noch gut ist und Tore machen kann, wie gegen den Klub, dann kann man Spiele auch gewinnen.
Du sagst es.
Also, ja. Albersberg auch von mir erstmal. So einen leichten Daumen, der kommt in der Kamera. Ganz leichter.
Ja, ich würde halt sagen, es ist halt auch einfach, also man hat halt sehr schnell diese 2. Liga verstanden. Und man muss einfach sagen, du hast gerade gesagt, das ist halt eben nicht mehr der spielerisch ansehnliche Fußball. Aber muss man auch einfach sagen, spielen sehr wenige Vereine in der 2. Liga ansehnlichen Fußball. Also das ist einfach so. Also der Fußball in der 2. Liga, I'm sorry to tell you, aber der ist halt einfach nicht gut über Weitere Strecken und das ist so. Ich musste eben kurz dran denken, als du über Düsseldorf gesprochen hast, Michi, dass sie am Ende dann doch nochmal rauskommen. Sagt eben halt auch viel über die Qualität der 2. Liga aus. Das ist ein anderes Thema. Aber man muss einfach sagen, einfach jetzt zu sagen, ja ganz ehrlich, und dann spielen wir der Durchschnitt der 2. Liga. Das zu schaffen, das wäre unter einem neuen Trainer auf jeden Fall auch schon mal ein, also das schaffen andere Vereine nicht. Liebe Grüße nach Braunschweig. So, ne, also das ist halt eben, wenn man das schafft, eben auf so einem, nicht unter so ein gewisses Niveau zu fallen eben im Spiel, dann ist das vollkommen in Ordnung. Und dann, also man kann es nicht vergleichen, aber wir haben es ja irgendwann noch mal bei Sandhausen gesehen, dass die eben über viele Jahre hinweg in der 2. Liga eigentlich nicht über so ein Grundlevel gefallen sind, bis sie es dann irgendwann getan haben. Und dann, ja, jetzt auch in der Regionalliga spielen. Aber ja, also generell, und dafür ist der Standort Elbersberg, du hast es gesagt, mit Ole Bog da auf jeden Fall sehr, sehr interessant besetzt. Sie haben übrigens im DFB-Pokal knapp gegen die SSV Ulm gewonnen. Eine Partie, die man fast ein bisschen vergessen hatte, glaube ich. Es war auch irgendwie schwarz-weißes Team gegen schwarz-weißes Team. Ist immer ein bisschen wild. Aber ja, generell sind wir da, glaube ich, auch gespannt. Lasst mich da auch noch ganz kurz gucken, was die nächsten Gegner sind. Das sind Hertha BSC am Freitag. Ich habe schon mal gesagt, mal gespannt, was wir da sehen. Dann kommt Dynamo Dresden und dann geht es zu Eintracht Braunschweig. Also, ja, mal schauen, was wir von Elbersberg in dieser Saison sehen. Und dann machen wir, glaube ich, einmal ganz kurz. Wir haben jetzt schon viele Teams besprochen. Auf Platz 3 der Liga steht gerade der Karlsruher SC. Ich weiß nicht, also man hat zwei Siege, einen Unentschieden, dieses Unentschieden gegen Hertha und ja, eben sonst zuletzt der Sieg. Aber ich weiß, gegen Braunschweig eben, ich weiß nicht, wie ihr das seht, aber es wirkt für mich halt wie klassischer KSC-Fußball bis jetzt. Also, beim KSC wirkt es bei mir nicht so, als wäre da jetzt irgendwie so wirklich Pause zwischen gewesen. Sie machen halt, klar, es ist halt auch vieles gleich geblieben. Die machen mit Christian Aichner da gefühlt weiter, wo sie aufgehört haben. Es ist irgendwie, die werden, glaube ich, also ich habe sie ja als Ausstiegskandidat getippt, weil meine Frage ist halt, ob sie es irgendwann mal schaffen, einmal diese Stufe nochmal draufzusetzen. Aber bisher, würde ich sagen, ist ein grundsolides Level. Also, ich weiß nicht, ob es den gibt.
Das kann ich unterschreiben. Also, das, was du sagst, finde ich gerade, ist auch das, was so mit meiner ersten Einschätzung, so nach den ersten Spieltagen, resoniert, dass ich auch sage, boah, sehe ich jetzt nicht ganz oben. Also, haben sich gut verkauft, sieben Punkte. Ich habe mir die Tabelle ja auch gerade nochmal aufgemacht. Kein absoluter Top-Favorit für mich. Andererseits, wer ist das auch? Oder was heißt das auch in der Liga? Das könnte für mich so ein klassischer Fall sein, von wir sitzen hier zwei, drei Spieltage vor Schluss und es ist ähnlich eng wie letztes Jahr. Und dann könnte Karlsruhe da oben mit dabei sein. Ähnlich wie Darmstadt, über die wir vielleicht auch gleich zwei, drei Sätze noch verlieren. Aber wären jetzt keine Clubs, auf die ich wetten würde, würde ich aber ehrlicherweise auch wieder bei kaum einem Verein gehen. So wie sich das gestaltet, auch jetzt nach den ersten Spieltagen noch weniger. Deshalb ja so ein bisschen eine Wundertüte vielleicht an der ein oder anderen Stelle, was nach oben oder vielleicht auch nach unten da noch kommen kann. Aber ich glaube, erst mal kann man da sowohl wenn man Karlsruhe oder auch Darmstadt-Fan ist, erst mal sich entspannt irgendwie auf die Schultern klopfen, glaube ich. Und man ist oben dabei. Und das ist ja schon mal so nach drei Spieltagen das, was einen beruhigt, was ein gutes Gefühl gibt. Und dann schauen wir einfach mal, wie es läuft mit den beiden Teams.
Zum KSC nur ganz kurz. Ich habe schon mal in einer der früheren Sendungen meine heimliche Liebe für Marvin Wannizek kundgetan. Da hat er verlängert. Und das ist ja auch so ein Spieler, weshalb ich den KSC auch sehr positiv sehe, weil immer wenn ich ihn spielen sehe, denke ich mir, warum spielt er nicht in der Bundesliga? Und also, dass dieser Spieler immer noch beim KSC ist, ja, er ist auch schon 32, aber er schafft es einfach konstant, den KSC besser zu machen. Und es macht jedes Mal Spaß, hinzuzuschauen und in dieser Mannschaft eine Konstante zu haben, aber auch junge Talente und dann auch aus dem eigenen Nachwuchs mit Pintu Pintu Rosa, das heißt, glaube ich, Ben Fahd. Also, das ist eine gute Mischung. Mit Simmich hat man einen weiteren Stürmer dazu geholt. Die Defensive ist, sagen wir mal, diese 2. Liga solide mit Marcel Franke und solchen Spielern. Aber das reicht auch. Also, da muss man sich auf jeden Fall keine Sorgen machen beim KSC. Und ja, auch das ist so ein Verein, da kann man sich diesen nächsten Schritt irgendwann mal erhoffen oder vielleicht muss er auch irgendwann mal kommen, weil mit dem neuen Stadion, das hat einfach jetzt, also man hat einen guten Nachwuchs, man hat ein neues Stadion gebaut, man hat einen Trainer, einen sehr guten Trainer, der auch einen Ansatz für den Fußball hat. Also da kann das schon irgendwann mal mehr kommen, aber auch da bin ich wieder getrieben von Spielen, wenn ich sie halt oft mal dann sehe. Also mindestens zweimal pro Saison sehe ich sie dann auch im Stadion. Und auch dieses Spiel, das letztes Jahr gegen Fürth, das war einfach von beiden Mannschaften wirklich schlecht. Und dann, so ein Spiel hat der KSC halt auch mal drin. Und deswegen glaube ich auch daran, dass sie um den Aufstieg mitspielen. Aber sie können da auf jeden Fall mitreden, wenn dann auch andere Mannschaften da oben mal wieder schwächeln, weil sie einfach einen guten Kader und einen guten Trainer haben. Aber das habe ich heute schon über einige gesagt. Wir müssen der Gefühl einfach acht Mannschaften aufsteigen am Ende.
Ja, ich glaube einfach, was Karlsruhe hat, ist diese, wir haben ganz, ganz am Anfang über so eine Achse gesprochen und die haben sie einfach. Und du kannst um diese Achse herum, da kannst du immer mal wieder Spieler austauschen. Aber das bleibt halt. Und dann, wie gesagt, mit Christian Eichner hast du im Prinzip so ein bisschen, weiß ich nicht, den Achsenlenker da. Und deshalb funktioniert das, glaube ich, auch ganz gut. Wie gesagt, meine große Frage ist, schaffen sie es halt wirklich mal irgendwann, diesen einen Schritt weiterzugehen? Michi, du hast da gute Punkte gemacht. Das wäre halt wirklich meine Frage. Aber sonst muss man einfach sagen, ja, sie sind halt, also wir haben es bei anderen Vereinen gesehen, z. B der FC Heidenheim, was irgendwann mal daraus entstehen kann, wenn du so eine gewisse Kontinuität im Kader auf dem Trainerposten hast, dass du dann eben irgendwann einfach diesen Vorteil hast. Und wir haben es halt schon öfter mal gesehen. Fürth hat es mal vorgemacht, Bochum hat es vorgemacht, Bielefeld hat es mal vorgemacht. Nein, aber im Sinne von, wenn du mal in so einer Saison, wo du keine klassischen Aufstiegskandidaten hast, weil die Absteiger eben nicht die ganz großen Namen sind, von denen man eben, wir haben es eben gesagt, oder es kommt auch immer wieder, die nicht klassisch direkt nach oben gehen könnten, sind das ja gerade solche Vereine, wo die Kontinuität eben herrscht, dass du es eben schaffst, da eben als Verein rauszubrechen. Aber genau, da wäre eben meine Frage, ob sie das schaffen. Frage ist da natürlich, also wir schauen erst einmal ganz kurz noch, also sie hatten eine sehr entspannte Leistung im DFB-Pokal 5-0 gegen Meuselwitz. Also da war keine Schmach irgendwie erkennbar. Das haben sie locker runtergespielt. Und da muss man sagen, wenn man sich so ein paar andere Vereine anguckt, auch wenn es keine großen Sensationen weitergehen gab, ist das ja schon durchaus ein Kompliment. Es geht jetzt Samstagabend gegen Fortuna Düsseldorf, dann nach der Länderspielpause gegen Nürnberg, sonntags gegen Kiel. Das sind eben die nächsten drei Spiele. Und dann lassen wir uns noch auf Platz 2 kurz gucken. Lisa, du hast es eben schon angesprochen, der SV Darmstadt 98, eben auch zwei Sieger, ein Unentschieden. Jetzt zuletzt eben dieses Unentschieden gegen die Hertha. Und ich glaube, Mark und ich fühlen uns ein bisschen bestätigt in unserer Aussage, dass– ich weiß, ihr konntet das allerdings nicht mehr hören– aber dass Darmstadt halt einfach so eine leichte Blackbox ist, weil du hattest dieses 4-0 gegen Bochum. Ja, dann hat man 1-0 gegen Nürnberg gewonnen, aber das war ja dann doch relativ weit weg von diesem Hurra-Wußball nach vorne, den man gegen Bochum gezeigt hat. Also der SVD-Express konnte gegen Nürnberg nicht so anrollen. Und jetzt hat man schon so– man hat direkt in den ersten drei Spieltagen so ein bisschen– das ist halt so das Darmstadt, was wir so ein bisschen erwarten. Es gibt auf jeden Fall Ausschläge nach oben, aber Darmstadt unter Kohfeldt haben immer so eine gewisse– sie haben so Schwankungen drin, die aber am Ende jetzt weder nach oben noch nach unten für großes Drama sorgen. Habe ich so immer bei Darmstadt das Gefühl.
Trainer reden ja immer gerne von Unterschiedsspielern, und wenn Isaac Liedberg da bleibt, ist er halt ein potenzieller Unterschiedsspieler. Das hat man gesehen am ersten Spieltag. Dieser Abschluss gegen Bochum war das 1-0 sogar. Ich habe vor Augen, wie er den Ball da rein hämmert. Das ist einfach wahnsinnig stark. Das kann in einer engen Liga auch. Wenn du einen Stürmer hast, der funktioniert, der dir 10 bis 15 Tore schießt, kann er auch den Unterschied in so engen Spielen nicht mehr ausmachen. Deswegen bin ich bei ihnen sehr optimistisch. Ich habe diese Black Box SV Darmstadt letztes Jahr auch gesehen. Sie haben hier 5-1 gewonnen. Man dachte, die steigen jetzt auf. Im Rückspiel war das eine der schlechtesten Fußballspiele, die ich je gesehen habe. Das kann Darmstadt beides in einer Saison schaffen. Sie können es auch innerhalb von einem Monat schaffen. Sie spielen wahnsinnig die Sterne vom Himmel. Sie spielen dann wieder so, dass man denkt, die 2. Liga muss man nicht für viel Geld als Zuschauer im Stadion anschauen. Das wird mir auch komplett unschlüssig. Aber es wird wieder eine Mannschaft sein, die wahrscheinlich Spaß macht an vielen Tagen und an manchen Tagen dann auch wieder weniger. Aber es wird nie langweilig werden, glaube ich, da am Stadion zu verfolgen.
Ich glaube, das, was du mit Black Box gerade schon so ein bisschen umschrieben hast, Eva, ist ja auch das, was man so ein bisschen zwischen erster und zweiter Spieltag zu sehen bekommen hat. Also ich war auch beeindruckt, wie man da Buchum überrollt hat, ehrlicherweise. Das war nicht das, was ich ehrlicherweise so am ersten Spieltag von beiden Teams erwartet hatte in beide Richtungen. Entsprechend war ich schon auch ein bisschen so mit der Clubbrille am zweiten Spieltag, ich will jetzt nicht sagen verängstigt, das wäre jetzt zu hoch gegriffen, aber hatte da schon Sorge, dass das das nächste Torfestival gibt. Und das Spiel lief ja dann komplett anders. Also das war wirklich am Ende ein glücklicher Sieg. Ja, am Ende fragt keiner mehr, wie hast du die Punkte gemacht und wo kommen sie her? Und hast du 1-0 gewonnen oder 4-0? Das ist ja auch Teil der Wahrheit, aber das Spiel hat mich nicht so überzeugt, dass ich jetzt sagen würde, die bleiben auf jeden Fall oben dran oder spielen mit. Ich glaube, es wird spannend, einfach zu beobachten, wie sich das entwickelt, ob Liedberg da bleibt oder nicht. Das ist natürlich auch ein großes Thema, das ihr gerade schon angerissen habt. Mein Gefühl ist, wenn ich über solche Clubs wie Karlsruhe oder Darmstadt rede, was sind so die Themen? Da ist halt relativ viel Ruhe drin. Also das ist das, was ich an Clubs ganz toll finde. Klar, die wollen gerne aufsteigen. Klar, die wollen gerne auch mal wieder in die 1. Liga. Für Darmstadt ist es auch noch nicht so lange her, ohne dass ich jetzt das komplett im Kopf hätte, mit den Jahreszahlen ganz schlimm, aber ist noch nicht so lange her. Aber das ist einfach ein anderes Umfeld. Und ich weiß, ein schwieriges Umfeld und so ein klassisches Thema bei Traditionsclubs. Aber da gucke ich dann immer so ein bisschen neidisch, zum Beispiel nach Karlsruhe oder nach Darmstadt, wo man sich jetzt, glaube ich, freut, dass man oben dabei ist, wo man jetzt aber auch keine überzogenen Erwartungen hat, dass man jetzt aufsteigen muss. Weil so große Teams, wie der HSV oder wie der FC Köln, nicht mehr in der Liga sind. Was es, glaube ich, auch einfacher macht an der ein oder anderen Stelle, dass einfach da ein bisschen mehr Ruhe drin ist. Es ist weder den Mega-Hype gibt nach einem Spiel, dass man eben so hoch gewinnt wie gegen Bochum oder auch mal nach einem Unentschieden oder nach einer Niederlage, dass es nicht ganz so tief dann ins Tal direkt runtergeht.
Ich glaube, Karlsruhe-Fans sind sehr froh, dass du sie als Ruhestelle kennst.
Kommt ein bisschen, ich weiß auch schon, wir hatten ja Podcasts, wo wir über die Situation von Karlsruhe, aber ich nehme die, das letzte halbe, dreiviertel Jahr als super entspannt war. Vielleicht habe ich auch die großen Themen versäumt, aber das hat sich für mich, finde ich, deutlich, deutlich gelegt, was es so im Verein, ehrlicherweise, an Themen gibt.
Ja, also natürlich bleibt das ganz, ganz große Thema, bleibt weiterhin natürlich dieses Rundums-Fan-Projekt, Karlsruhe. Also ich glaube, das war ja das große Thema neben dem Platz, sicherlich. Und ja, da, wo Karlsruhe natürlich auch, vor allem die Fans sind natürlich auch immer sehr, sehr lautstark, weiter hingegen protestiert bzw. im Namen des Fanprojekts natürlich auch lautstark, was unternimmt. Aber generell, also ich glaube, einmal noch zu Liedberg bei Darmstadt, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, wurde eben nach dem Spiel gesagt, dass bis auf Riedel, der aber ja eh schon nicht im Kader stand und ich glaube zu Espanyol, Barcelona wechselt, niemand mehr den Verein verlassen soll. Also das war die offizielle Aussage. Ja, wir können immer einen Stand jetzt hinterher schieben. Wir wissen, wie der Fußball funktioniert. Aber das war jetzt so die letzte Aussage. Und dann ist es natürlich wirklich ein absolutes Faustpfand. Wir werden da in zwei Wochen nochmal drauf gucken und schauen, ob wir da Recht behalten hatten. Aber sicherlich, das wäre sonst ein Gewinn für den SVD. Aber wie gesagt, also ich glaube, ich bleibe dabei. Es liegt bei mir nicht am Kader, warum ich bei Darmstadt eben diese Schwingung sehe, sondern einfach an Florian Kohfeldt. Und daran bleibe ich auch, dass ich da manchmal nicht so ganz weiß, was denn jetzt seine Idee vom Fußball spielen ist, was die man so richtig durchgehend sieht. Das ist, glaube ich, mein Hauptproblem, wo ich dann deshalb sage, okay, ich weiß nicht klar, wo ich sie einordnen soll. Dann lasst uns doch noch als allerletztes, diese Folge ist schon wieder länger geworden als geplant, wer hätte es ahnen können, auf Hannover 96 gucken. Die haben den perfekten Saisonstart aller Teams hingelegt, drei Siege in drei Spielen. Wir blenden jetzt einfach mal ganz vorsichtig das DFB-Pokalspiel gegen Energie Cottbus aus. Aber man muss auch da sagen, in Hannover rechnet man mit diesem Erstrunden meistens aus. Genau, und es gab ein durchaus unterhaltsames 3 zu 1 gegen den 1. FC Magdeburg, das Tits-Derby könnte man so sagen. Man muss aber auch sagen, ja, durchaus deutlicher Spielstand, aber ich finde, Magdeburg hat über weite Strecken durchaus dazu beigetragen, dass man dieses Fußballspiel sehr, sehr gut angucken konnte. Aber man muss einfach sagen, Hannover hat sehr früh in der Saison einfach, ja, die können ihre individuelle Klasse und ihre Effizienz vom Tor einfach gnadenlos gut ausspielen, auf jeden Fall in den Ligaspielen. Kaelmann als Joker auch wieder getroffen, Bundu war wieder dabei, der ist zwar noch nicht so torgefällig, wie er gerne wäre, aber also man sieht dann auch schon, warum ein Zweitligist ihn sich leisten konnte am Ende des Tages. Aber er ist einfach ein unfassbar wichtiges spielerisches Element. Man muss wirklich sagen, also Stand jetzt, nach drei Ligaspieltagen ist Hits voll und ganz bei Hannover 96 angekommen. Michi, wie stehst du dazu?
Ja, würde man sagen, die heißeste Mannschaft der Liga. Nicht nur aufgrund dieser neuen Punkte, sondern auch wenn man es anschaut. Und das ist dann schon überraschend. Letzter Fettbezug in dieser Folge dazu. Auch da hat man einen großen Unbruch gemacht. Die Zahlen sind ähnlich. Also wenn ich richtig gezählt habe, 12 Abgänge, 15 Zugänge bei Hannover. Aber halt auch nicht Zugänge, die allesamt irgendwie schon mal die 2. Liga kennen, wie das ja Expertinnen und Experten gerne sagen, sondern die aus– ich habe es mir aufgeschrieben– Frankreich, Polen, England, Südafrika, Japan, Schottland kamen, da dann schon so schnell mit einem neuen Trainer, mit einem neuen Trainerteam eine Mannschaft zusammenzubauen, die 9 Punkte holt, die guten Fußball spielt, die auch nicht glücklich 3-1 gewonnen hat, sondern auch, wenn man die Daten anschaut, dass auch vollkommen verdient war, dass man da 3 Tore gemacht hat. Die natürlich haben auch 3 Neuzugänge dann gleich getroffen. Gut, bei so vielen ist dies ja bescheid. Dann ist es einfacher, wenn jeder Spieler neu ist, dann treffen wir auch nur neue Spieler. Aber das sieht einfach sehr gut aus. Auch da ist ja das Umfeld, wenn man Hannover hätte, also war ja lange ein Bundesligastandort, ist es so immer noch, wenn man dort im Starten ist. Das finde ich auch. Die Stadt ist eine große Stadt. Da ist vieles dafür da, um wieder einen Bundesligaufstieg zu schaffen. Vielleicht hat man mit Christian Titz genau den Trainer jetzt geholt, der dann da die hohen Anschwäche, die man sich ja auch hat, für einen guten Fußball verbinden kann mit einem guten Kader. Man ist immer noch finanziell gut aufgestellt. Da muss man jetzt auch nicht so viel sparen. Insofern finde ich schon mal sehr, sehr gut, was da passiert. Ich bin überrascht, wie gut das dann auch aussehen kann nach so einem Neustart, schon nach drei Spielen. Wie gesagt, ich finde das ist fast die größte Leistung neben der neuen Punkt, dass man so viele verschiedene Spieler aus so vielen verschiedenen Ligen, die aus unterschiedlichen Niveaus kommen, auch mit verschiedenen Sprachen, dass man die so schnell vereinen kann. Das ist schon richtig stark.
Da muss ich gestehen, das hätte ich ehrlicherweise auch nicht erwartet und war das, was mich überrascht hat. Ich weiß noch, wie ich meine Tipps für die Auf- und Absteiger, abgegeben habe, dass ich über eine Datenanalyse vom Global Soccer Network gestolpert bin. Ich habe mir den Titel hier noch mal aufgeschrieben, wie TILZ 96 zum Aufstieg führt auf datenbasierte Analyse. Ich war auch schon so, okay, verstehe ich, was mir da alles erklärt wird, aber weiß ich nicht, ob das nicht zu optimistisch ist, weil Daten sind das eine und die Menschen dahinter, ein neues Team aufzubauen, ein Teamgefüge aufzubauen, auch einfach einen Fußball spielen zu lassen, der dann passt und der das System des Trainers verkörpert. Das hätte ich ehrlicherweise schon gar nicht in der kurzen Zeit nicht erwartet. Deswegen, ich habe Hannover nicht getippt. Jetzt ärgere ich mich so ein bisschen, weil man hätte es vielleicht sehen können, wenn man sich die Daten so tief angeguckt hat. Du hattest ja auch vorhin schon gesagt, Eva, 2. Liga-Fußball ist selten schön und macht selten Spaß. Hannover habe ich mir jetzt echt gerne die letzten Spieltage angeguckt, weil die einfach Fußball spielen. Die sind mutig, die haben viel Ballbesitz, die stehen aber auch hinten total stabil. Das hat wirklich Spaß gemacht, muss ich sagen. Deshalb würde ich da auch mitgehen bei Sind ein heißes Eisen. Ich weiß nicht, wer sie getippt hat aus unserer Runde. Da müsste ich vielleicht nochmal im Großen... Ah, da würde ich vielleicht sagen Glückwunsch. Nach den ersten drei Spieltagen würde ich da jetzt auch nochmal umschwenken, weil wirklich ganz, ganz viel schon klappt. Ich finde, man hat auch so prominente Abgänge, finde ich. So Trezoldi habe ich jetzt nicht groß vermisst, die ersten Spiele über. Also, das war ja auch so ein bisschen das eine oder andere, so wie verstärkt man sich und ja, wer fehlt denn dann da und wie wird es? Also, da muss ich echt sagen, hätte ich nicht erwartet, hat mich total überrascht, dass das direkt so funktioniert, wie es funktioniert. Also, gut ab an den ersten drei Spieltagen in Richtung Hannover.
Meine Frage wäre jetzt eben noch, wie schaffen sie es denn? Also, natürlich hast du nicht 1 zu 1 Energie Cottbus in der 2. Liga, aber man muss einfach da sagen, also Cottbus hat dann schon gezeigt, womit Hannover Probleme haben könnte, wenn sie eben, ja klar, Ballbesitzfußball ist jetzt Fußball, aber halt gegen Teams, die halt auch wirklich tief stehen und dann aber eine Körperlichkeit mitbringen, die halt so, also, na, Hannover hatte die besseren Chancen, aber sie haben ein Tor halt eben nicht gemacht. Und gleichzeitig dann halt doch einmal zu anfällig, sind über die Außen nicht richtig durchgekommen. Und da sieht man dann schon, dass es da vielleicht doch ein, zwei Punkte gibt, wo du 96 eben unter Teams auch knacken kannst. Jetzt als nächstes eben gegen Kiel auswärts, zu Hause gegen die Hertha und auswärts gegen Dynamo Dresden. Und auf das Spiel, wie gesagt, bin ich auch sehr, sehr gespannt, was wir da dann sehen. Also weil, wenn Dresden so auftritt wie gegen Bielefeld und dann eben vielleicht auch nicht so viele Balle haben will und Hannover muss das Spiel machen, da bin ich schon durchaus gespannt, was wir da von 96 sehen. Aber man muss schon einfach sagen, also ich glaube, Hannover-Fans trauen dem Raten da auch noch nicht so ganz, weil sie einfach, glaube ich, auch viel enttäuscht worden sind die letzten Jahre. Aber ich muss sagen, es scheint wirklich per se zu passen. Markus Mann hat da gute Arbeit geleistet. Der hat dann natürlich auch gewisse Sicherheiten. Bei Hannover natürlich nie Ruhe neben dem Platz, auch das wissen wir alle. Da gibt es, glaube ich, jetzt auch gerade die Abstimmung, wie die neuen Stadionsitze farblich gestaltet werden sollen, wenn ich das richtig gesehen habe. Also auch sehr wild. Aber ich meine, gut, wir alle kennen die von Fortuna Düsseldorf. Ich würde das auch die Fans entscheiden lassen wollen, wie das aussieht. Aber gut, generell muss man aber echt sagen, Hannover 96 macht Spaß. Hannover erfüllt die Vorstellung von vielen. Also wie gesagt, ich glaube, es war eben, Lisa, du hast es, was viele Leute tatsächlich beschäftigt hat. Also schafft es Tiet sofort, eben diesen großen Umbruch zu verarbeiten. Und Stand jetzt muss man sagen, tut er. Ich glaube nicht, dass sie jedes Spiel bis zum Ende der Saison gewinnen werden. Aber man muss ja sagen, vielleicht dahin gehen doch gar nicht mal so schlecht, dass sie aus dem Pokal raus sind. Das heißt, Belastungssteuerung etc. PP können sie sich vollends auf die 2. Liga verlassen. Und das ist sicherlich keine nur schlechte Idee für Hannover.
Und wenn es einen Trainer gibt, dem man zutraut, einen tiefstehenden Gegner gut zu bespielen, dann ja wohl Christian Titz, der das in Magdeburg ein paar Exelos gezeigt hat, dass man auch mit 65 Prozent beibeisetzt. Wenn die Automatismen klappen, wenn man sich besser kennt, dann auch. Es war ein Gegnerbespiel und klar, gegen Kiel und Hertha werden es jetzt auch nicht immer nur den Ball haben, es müssen auch zwei Mannschaften, die spielen wollen. Wie du sagst, dann wird es gegen Dresden vielleicht spannender, aber es sind halt auch noch drei Wochen mit einer Länderspielpause dazwischen. Also in diesen drei Wochen kann man schon noch, jetzt fast vier, aber drei Spiele. Also da kann man schon auch einiges noch einstudieren.
Ja, und es zeigt natürlich...
Wir müssen noch mal eine These untermauern, dass hier.
Naja, und man muss auch einfach sagen, also Hannover zeigt halt, wie wichtig es ist, wenn ein Kader früh steht. Und dann kann es fast sogar, ich sag mal in Anführungszeichen, egal sein, wie viel Umbruch es gab. Weil das haben sie jetzt einfach, sie konnten einfach anfangs an mit gefühlt 80 Prozent der 11, die jetzt auf dem Platz steht, eben arbeiten. Und das ist einfach ein Unterschied. Und ich glaube, ja, mit Hannover werden wir noch viel Spaß haben. Ich würde jetzt aber sagen, wir hatten jetzt genug Spaß. Vielen Dank, dass ihr euch beide doch so lange Zeit genommen habt. Es war die erste Folge in diesem neuen Format. Ich glaube, wir können uns sicher sein, wir werden nicht immer über alle Vereine so viel sprechen, aber wir dachten, wir nehmen das jetzt doch mal alles so ein bisschen mit rein, weil es eben viele Storys zu erzählen gibt an die Vereine, die wir jetzt nicht besprochen haben, oder an die Fans dieser Vereine. Seid nicht böse, eure Vereine kommen sicherlich in der nächsten Folge wieder dran. Es ist vielleicht auch ab und zu ein Kompliment, wenn man noch nicht über sie spricht. Und sonst natürlich der Hinweis noch mal. Gestern ist die Folge zum ersten Spieltag, der Bundesligaspieltag der Männer erschien, mit Petra Neher und Max Eichinger. Da könnt ihr auch noch gerne reinhören, wenn ihr es noch nicht gemacht habt. Und sonst hören wir uns in zwei Wochen wieder. Da bin ich auch wieder hier. Und Marc hört ihr dann irgendwann Mitte September wieder. Versprochen. Und dann, wie gesagt, bedanke ich mich ganz, ganz herzlich bei Lisa Höfer. Danke, dass du dabei warst. Mal wieder.
Vielen, vielen Dank. Ich freue mich total, dass es geklappt hat. Das nächste Mal vielleicht mit ein paar positiveren Clubgeschichten. Aber wir schauen, was kommt.
Und lieben Dank natürlich auch an Michi Fischer, ausnahmsweise mal hier, ohne über die Spielvereinigung viel zu sprechen. Danke, Michi.
Ganz ohne ging es ja nicht. Aber ich habe mich bemüht, möglichst wenig darüber zu sprechen. Danke für die Einladung. Hat mir immer sehr viel Spaß gemacht.
Ja, und sagt gerne, was ihr von dieser Folge gehalten habt. Und bis bald. Das war der Rasenfunk.
Von Ihnen unterstützt.
Herzlichen Dank.
Bei anderen sprießen die Gehälter, bei uns nur der Rasen.